I think we sold so many
flashlights that does.
It was impossible for them to sell more
because everyone who listens to the show
is a pervert. No way they'd tap
the market. So what? I mean,
you can only advertise with
someone for so long. I mean,
everybody listens to this show has
heard about the fleshlight by now.
It makes sense that they wouldn't be a
spot or the relationship. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Well, it's not that they
backed out. It says we ended it.
We did it for a long time. So
this is totally amicable. Cool.
They're very nice guy. Coca Cola is,
but you keep advertising, Jack. I don't,
I don't. Not at run in any companies, man.
I don't give a fuck. I tweet them still.
I still talk to them. They're great
guys. Good video that they just posted.
That's crazy.
I just couldn't keep up with the
first product ever where they stopped
advertising because that people,
they couldn't keep up with the demand.
That's true. I'm just joking around about
that. I mean, it makes sense. The only,
the only product ever is a fake vagina.
That's the only one that they'd have to,
they'd run out of materials.
I don't understand what you're saying.
That skin is rare. You know
how they make that skin? Yeah.
It's actually a food based, um, uh,
product. I'm chewing on one right now.
It's like,
it's not really like a plastic,
it's almost like you could almost
like digest it with your body.
It's really weird. You got to check
out the, they just posted a video.
Just go, what the fuck that I walked
in? What did we walk it? Let's not,
this isn't even a real sponsor.
We're actually sponsored by on at.com
makers of a Alpha brain, shroom tech,
shroom tech, sports room, tech immune.
And uh, also we recently got hacked,
ladies and gentlemen, we
got hacked. They got in,
got ahold of some encrypted data and um,
that you could, it's all explained it.
ana.com forward slash breach.
Uh, and because of that,
they're offering an 18% discount off of
everything for the next couple of days.
So you just use the code name,
got your back. People are, uh,
very bummed out over there that
someone hacked into the system.
But that's just the way it goes,
man. If you're, if you're online,
someone can get you those little script
kitties, those bad motherfuckers.
Apparently it wasn't
the best setup at on it.
They've radically improved it because
of that and they feel terrible about it.
She said they just didn't know.
It's a fairly new company,
but I've been hacked three times.
Just a gas station this year and you know,
I mean I've had to change my,
all my shit gas stations all the time.
Something happens when you run your
card through that thing and they can,
they need to stick. Yeah.
When you slide it through the,
and when you run your card through and
then you put in your, your zip code,
apparently some of them are rigged and
some of them just copy your information
like, and then they have to figure
out which gas station it was,
where were you when it happened,
which machine did you use?
And then they find out and go in the
machine and find out who rigged it so they
can be Rick. Bye. Yeah, it could be that.
It could be a third party
that transmits that data.
It's really pretty sophisticated.
It's, it's really nuts really.
But there's a lot of money in organized
crime and stealing credit cards is a big
part of it. And so it's just fucking
super common. If you're online,
people are going to go after you.
That's that discount also works
on kettle bells and battle ropes.
So all shit to become manly.
Go get some. All right.
And thanks to Alienware MMA for hooking
us up with some dope laptops and go
death squad.tv and pick yourself up some,
some cat shirts.
So that's the kind of shirts that I like.
Are you going to keep selling
the first one? Uh, no,
but I do have like a box of the old ones
leftover that I may eventually put on
sale. There's only like it like a
hundred of them lot. The old one's dope.
I like the new one.
The old one.
I would love it if you had that for
sale as well cause I just think it's the
shit that, that cat though was awesome.
That cat is the future. Alright,
you dirty pitches. Kat Von d
is here. Buckled the fuck up.
The real cat play the music Brian.
So it can be official
experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
There's a lot of shit over it on and talk,
comment he about,
I don't have to talk about all the
products. Get it. Sometimes it just,
I just half for a while there dude.
I was very impressed with your
enthusiasm and your passion during those
commercials when the
passion is still every time.
Well it's just based on reality.
It's based on the last me all the time.
Dude is that shit for real people to
ask me that all the time. I'm like dude,
Joe would not be involved in
some shit that didn't work.
He's only involved in shit that works.
Trust me,
you don't take it every day at mine. If
you, if you're interested in nootropics,
there's a lot of stuff that you can get
on your own and just buy it in bulk and
it's way cheaper than doing this like
what we've done. But just go Google it.
It's, it's fascinating shit. It's
vitamins for your brain. It works.
You don't need that. You clever woman.
No, you're on top of shit already.
Imagine the tattoos on shroom tech.
My friend Eddie Bravo is here with Kat
von d because Kat von d actually wrote on
Eddie browse chest,
pull it up.
I haven't shaved my chest in a long time,
so it's kind of a Paul
Stanley false tail leash.
That's my grandmother.
Wow. I love that Tattoo.
That was three years ago,
something like that.
That is uh, my, what I think is the
most impressive style of artwork.
That reproduction of portraits.
Yeah.
I saw this,
I saw this girl last night that had her
father on her arm as a child though.
And instead just as this little
child on her arm, and I'm like,
has anyone ever tried to like
it? Does it, is it messy?
Is it weird when people are like, you
know, like I tried to make him blink,
you know, like as a baby and like
fucker whipped the face and it's like,
is that weird to you? She goes, no,
this guy's cummed on it before and I
made him lick it off and I'm like, what?
Like that's just crazy.
Like there's realistic tattoos.
I don't know what the hell he just said.
I think Brian like you need to go take
some medicine for a second. Then I'm like,
damn, I smoke too much with too
much. We get no, I think Brian did.
You just went too deep. Right? You just
got ran up a ramp covered in Vaseline.
Definitely too much weight on my house.
I have to deal with him
by myself sometimes. I was
trying to remember this crazy.
I was trying to remember the
story that happened last night,
but then I was too stoned to remember it.
So then I was like trying to stumble
what telling his daughter just got a slow
down side and the crazy
it's going to be okay.
The crazy thing about how this tattoo
came about was her shop is one was one
block away from old legends.
Remember that? Yeah. I pass by
legends is a, an MMA gym that
I was in Hollywood. Yeah. Yeah.
It was a kickbox. I'm just right
down the street from your shop.
So I would pass by to go home.
I lived in north Hollywood.
I would pass by to and from work
all the time. It always your tech.
I never saw your show,
but I knew who you were from the
billboards around Hollywood and shit.
But I never, ever, not once thought
about ever getting a tattoo for me.
I just didn't think about it. I haven't,
I know what happened. My Guy, Carson Hill,
you know, I just, I have this
tattoo artist who's awesome name,
name is Carson Hill is an La fucking
amazing, but I was, I'm cool with them.
I'm only going to let him fuck with my
shit now. That's what I was thinking.
But then after like a year
of just passing by your shop,
I ended up in the u at the UFC in Dallas.
We were in Dallas and
there wasn't shit to do.
And I used to work for the UFC and I'm
sitting here in my hotel room and to all
my show comes up at Alma
awards. It's like, oh, I was
there. My mom, it's like one.
Yeah. So I'm watching
this, the Alma awards,
is that the Latino celebrity awards or
whatever, and I'm watching that, you know,
meet, be being Latin, you
know, I'm like, Oh shit,
I didn't know that white dude
was fucking half Mexican,
like actors are coming up and rock stars.
You're talking about me. I'm like, oh no,
no, no. And then, and then, and then
Kat von d comes up and I'm like,
Oh shit, she's Mexican. Holy Shit.
I didn't know I was born in Mexico,
but my family's from Argentina. So
I am Latino, but I'm on mic. Yeah.
So at that point, your family's from
Argentina. Yeah. Wow. That's cool. Yeah.
So at that point, let me, let me finish
this real quick. So at that point,
now she's in my head, I might
think, oh, she's Mexican.
So that was Friday afternoon,
Monday,
first class after class.
It's 11 o'clock at night.
I'm driving pastor shop. It's closed
up and I'm thinking, oh, wild hair.
Just delusional thought.
Hey,
maybe I could get her to do a tattoo on
me and film it and put it on my show.
They can like, like she would actually
do it. I'm thinking for 10 seconds.
I'm thinking that's a good idea.
But then as I made a right on Santa Monica
Boulevard, I'm like, she's so famous.
She would never do that. I'm like,
what a crazy dumb thought. I go home,
take a shower to get a late night
bite to eat at kitchen 24 by myself.
I just walked in. I'm
quite good. Yeah. Sat there
and this girl comes up to me that I
knew from a long time with Jason's
ex-girlfriend, Jason Chambers. Ex
girlfriend comes up to us, Eddie,
what's up and she gives me hugs. Oh
Shit. And she looks at me and goes,
you should let Kat von d tattoo
you. I'm like, that is crazy.
Because I was just thinking
that an hour and a half ago.
That's insane or whatever. I'm like,
that's a pretty crazy. You're like,
tell us what happened. And then
she goes, no, but I'm serious.
I could actually get you on the
show. I'm like, what? He goes,
yeah I work on the show. They
hired me. That shit ain't real.
Just interesting that you came in
writing on that vehicle because we wasn't
really,
honestly would have probably worked more
against you than for you but somehow
you want eat it.
But she was bros with the casting
director and she goes to casting director
loves USC.
Well she did.
She did get me on the shot and for that
I am grateful for you all. Thank you.
So she's funny.
Winship worksite Wayne when you have some
weird ideas and all that stuff here it
becomes reality.
The next morning I meet
the casting director and he
said let's do it cause he's
a big UFC fan and I was just right
there on the show and you know what they
originally she got, they go, cat is
very picky on who she does tattoos,
what's true. So she doesn't pick
you. Will you go with the other two?
And I said No. You on the fence
at all? Um, well, you know,
it's when we would film the show if
there was like a screening process,
so like I would get these lists
of different ideas and peep,
peep requests I guess. And so
I would, based on the artwork,
I would filter through and do the ones
that I knew that I was capable of or I'd
be excited about.
Um,
but they wouldn't really tell me much
about the person come in because they want
it to be all natural on camera and stuff.
So I didn't know. I don't, I think a new,
very minimal other than your
name. I didn't know. She
didn't know. She just for,
they said no. Very strange.
Yeah. I said I wouldn't do it.
I felt that was so crazy that I thought
of it that night and an hour and a half
later, some chick makes it happen. I
thought it was so crazy that I said, no,
I won't do it unless cat does
it. I'm not interested. Yeah.
Yeah.
That is really odd when things like that
happen because there's no denying it
that like statistically
put that shit on paper.
How crazy the thought you'll store into
your head on paper and then meeting.
Well, what are the odds of that?
That's like fucking millions to one.
It's almost like they're,
the story of your life is like the DA.
The writers are working on it last and
it's just getting shittier and easier for
things to happen.
It's like instead of big,
some complicated fucking Warren peace,
epic have, you know, a complicated,
I do 20 personalities.
No,
I just think about some shit and
the next day you get a phone call.
It's like an hour, hour and a
half late. Imagine if you had,
imagine if you had like a bunch of magic
gifts and you did know about them and
you would just use it.
I'm on tattoos and shit.
When you could even maybe fly or
breathe under water or something,
you know, like you might've had a
magic gift and you, you made it happen.
You're like, maybe get a handful
of those in your life. I told him.
And you just decided to do
it on make it happen. Yeah.
It's crazy actually when you think it,
it
would even if you had like a little magic,
like the ability to make something happen,
a few gifts like that in your life,
you're really not gonna be able to do
anything that's truly supernatural.
I mean it would have
already been done already.
So like when you look at someone who's
got like a tattoo is actually one of the
best things you can do.
You know,
get something that's permanent artwork
on s on your skin. That to you,
I know means an incredible amount.
And to get it from someone like her
and to get it all in like one bit,
that's really is better
than like most magic tricks
that you know. Right. It's
fucking incredible. I was
trying to tell the stories,
the producers,
they didn't want to hear that shit
cause they didn't want to hear that.
One of the chicks that worked on
the show like pulled the string,
they didn't want it to
make that part of the show.
And the second is breaks the halls
of reality. Yeah. They, so they,
I was telling that story. I'm like, I
got an incredible story, but they got it.
We don't want hear that story.
Oh, that's a great story.
Why wouldn't they tell that story?
Because then it shows that someone
got dragged in and pulled strings.
I think it's smarter on
the, I mean, you know, the,
the reliability on that in comparison
to your, your actual story, you know,
like what you do and what it took to
get you there and the meaning behind the
tattoos a lot more, I guess. Um, you know,
it resonates with the viewer
much more than saying, oh,
this is a Hollywood moment. I
was at fucking, you know, cafe.
Think of it as a Hollywood moment though.
I think for him it's just a crazy
piece of synchronicities. Yeah.
And I think we ended up actually
talking about that kind of stuff anyway,
like throughout the, yeah, I was,
I may have told you that
story before we file for you.
A big fan of synchronicity. Do, do
a experience in your life. Yeah. Oh,
I'm a big fan of being the master of
your own reality. I think, you know,
it's not so much about wishing your way
through something or manifesting it,
but you know, I think certain mental
attitudes and mentalities that are,
are more productive than others.
Well, we know that certain
attitudes, I mean you,
you've talked about it like
that John Sarno back thing.
Like if you have like some
sort of, uh, like you,
you could be upset or angry at things
and have a bad back and think that you're
bad back is actually like an injury.
So it's not even an injury.
It literally is your own brain causing
your body to not up and some sort of a
crazy way that's painted deprives,
I don't know the exact science behind it,
but when you have some serious
stress in your life somehow,
this is a theory that I heard. I didn't
make this up. Your body, the pain is real.
Your body will suffocate your,
or deprive oxygen to the,
your back muscles and then
they get really sore and tight.
That's what happens when you get
nervous or stressful. That's the theory,
you know, it Kinda makes sense
because I have, I have, uh,
a backstory as well, but I don't want
to get into that. But I believe it,
that's a long story. We got to, we're
here to talk about, my thinking was that,
you know, you really do change a lot
of shit with your mind. I mean your,
your mind just in the things that
you come up with, like your artwork.
Do you mean it doesn't,
it doesn't ever feel like sometimes like
where were the fuck is this coming from?
This is almost like,
like it's coming out of nowhere.
It's coming into your creativity,
you know,
it's coming out of this
weird place in your mind.
Then all of a sudden it's manifested
itself in this beauty. These,
is it ever like freak you out?
Um, I don't know if it freaks me out. I
just get excited about things, you know?
And I mean, I dunno, I'm in love
with my job. I love, I mean,
I can't even call it my job. That'd
be so weird to say that, you know,
or I guess I'm the luckiest
person on the planet. But yeah,
I think it's just more, um, perspective
really. I think for year, well, you know,
I've been tattooed since I was 14 years
old and I got into my first hat two shot
when I was 16. Um, illegal. We obviously,
and I never went through like
a traditional apprenticeship
or anything like that,
but then, um, this,
this funny idea for a TV show
happened when I was like 21,
22 and it changed the dynamics of things.
You know,
at the time I was drinking and partying
a lot. And so I'm sober now, but, um,
it was like, I almost had resentment
towards people, uh, you know,
after doing like a lot of the
same stuff over and over again,
and the expectations that come in and
kind of like rapes the art at times,
you know, because you just want to, I
mean, for me, I just wanted to create,
I just wanted to draw her tattoo
and do my best and then, you know,
the story behind the Tattoo
and all that. It just, it,
it gets pretty heavy after a
while, but then, uh, you know,
something flipped and I saw
each opportunity or each
tattoo as an opportunity to
connect with people, you
know? And I think, I think
I'm always looking for that.
You know, I, I sound
like a Hippie, but like,
I like making people feel good
about things and about life,
whether it's about death or whatever.
It does sound like a Hippie, but it's
beautiful. But you know, it's like, it's,
it's a weird thing that we, we mock stuff
like that. I don't, I mean, I just, I'm,
I'm locking myself more than anything
because I catch myself sounding that way.
I do as well. Yeah. I catch myself
sounding like a retard. I'm like,
what are you talking about?
Idealistic fool or ethnicity,
but that would be the best way to live
if we all could figure out how to tune in
like that and everybody could,
I feel like I'm always at my most creative
when I'm being generous and kind and
nice to as many people as possible.
Yeah. Experienced, uh, you know, a,
a good connectivity with all the
human beings interact with. Totally.
You feel better.
You feel like it's working better.
Why don't you recognize your power as it?
Yeah.
Individual, you know, and I think like
intentions are really important. You know,
there's like this, this little thing that
I do and I think I've only told like,
uh, like one person about it.
At the end of every tattoo,
I put this paper towel
on the Tattoo and I,
I put like witch Hazel, which is
like a natural astringent and stuff.
And it's like,
I always like hold my hands over it for
a minute and I do think that the client,
most of the time thinks I'm just
like cleaning it off or something.
But in my mind I'm thinking
like several words then,
and this is really going to
sound like a crazy, I dunno,
like Voodoo hippie thing,
but I just think these three words and um,
and it's like a transfer
of energy and whatever.
Well, the three words,
oh, I'm telling you,
you can't tell me the three words
really where they secret. Yeah, I'm on.
They're just words. Why would you know
it's impossible. The color matching,
it's impossible to collection.
It's like Rainbow Chicken Salad.
No, I want to hear it. Why can't
you tell us? It's just words.
Just words. Just kidding. Well, I
mean, I think that would help people.
You fire them up whenever they
started doing that with their life.
Well, I mean [inaudible] mantras and stuff
and you know, whatever works for you.
If they want to try the Kat von d mantra,
it's so successful shirts,
then forget it when maybe you have
some magic. She like, you have it up.
Do you have magic? We all
have magic. But, um, no,
the purpose of being is that
there's like intention behind every,
every everything you do.
And um,
and I think that's really important
because there is like a physical aspect of
energy, you know, when people are like,
oh, like vibes and all that stuff,
there's actual energy that you're
putting out into the world. So,
and focus, I mean, we all know
when someone's not focusing on us,
when you're having a conversation,
when they're looking at their phone
or doing something else. Yeah.
Meet people and they're just like,
they're just dickheads or they're angry
or they're having a bad day or it's hot
or whatever.
And I have like witnessed it before
where I can like bring presence or
positivity into a situation,
you know? Or it's like, uh,
I recognize my power to do that.
And it's like,
I remember one time I was driving
down the brand, like I got a,
the chick behind me wasn't
paying attention and she
totally crashed into my car.
And then the guy behind her wasn't paying
attention and he crashed into her and
his airbags went off and all this
shit, you know? And I'm like,
my car is like pretty
stealth is not going to get,
I don't even think I got a ding on it,
you know?
And the cars behind me were just like
tin cans and I just remember going to
getting out of the car.
I mean I'm wearing like full leather and
just like you can just like, you know,
and that could be pretty
intimidating and I'm like, oh, okay,
I'm going to consciously like make
these people feel okay. You know?
And like she rolled down her window,
she's like, oh. And I remember going, Hey,
are you okay?
And just like looking at her and I,
and like asking her if she's okay and she,
she just like softened and
after like what kill me.
Yeah.
By the end of the crazy gang
banger check ham damage.
Yeah.
If I was a check I'd be so bummed out if
I remember when did you and the and to
know afterwards we were
all laughing about it.
I think that we have the power to do that.
Most people get all like up in arms
about things and I just realized I wrote
something and when I was a kid that the
nothing has any meaning other than the
meaning that you give it.
Yeah,
just totally and you could
force things to be positive.
If you can force all negative situations
to be opportunities for growth,
you know you can, you can, you can
live your life like that. Totally.
Where it can be a fuckhead just
slam it into walls everywhere and,
and live in misery. Never
figure it out. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You forgot your first
tattoo when you were 16
I got my first to one was 14 actually.
Holy was it good? Yeah. I still have it.
It's like a little j on my ankle.
It was for my first love ever and we
did it for like three years and wow,
that's intense. Yeah. Run, ran away. Like,
who does the cross the
country in a greyhound bus.
How old were you when you did that?
Uh,
but then I was 15 when I'm all across and
then I was already tattooing and stuff.
So Jesus Christ, yeah, you got now
you could put a z under it and,
and put 99 problems in
quotes and I don't know that,
but I just tell people it stands
for Jesus or just kidding.
Just kidding. That's funny. Yeah.
Wow.
That's a really young age to be
traveling. I know my portrait Aaron's
man and I had a hard time, like, uh,
I think forgiving myself for a long time
because I'm really close with my dad
and stuff. He actually like lived
with me up until recently and um,
he got his own place and I was
pretty bummed about that. But yeah,
at the time I was like, Oh, you know, I
never want to hurt anybody's feelings.
I just really felt like
the need to do this,
this thing that my family
didn't understand, you know,
and they're from a different
culture, like I said, and stuff.
So they weren't really prepared for it.
You know, they just seem like tattooing,
oh my God,
you're like a hoodlum or gangster,
a drug addict or a hooker or whatever.
Yeah, I was none of the above.
So they never put in their head,
you're doing tattoos. Boom,
you're going to be some
crazy famous check.
No, I mean, you know, and
we were, we lived a really
isolated world. Like you know,
the way we were brought up was not
very Americanized. It also like, which,
which I'm glad because I feel like that
that's really honestly the one things I
credit to like being able to do all things
I've done is just like the discipline.
And you know, the three of
us, my brother, sister and I,
we were all like classically trained
on the piano since I was six. And um,
you know,
two hours a day we had a practice and
when we would rather be like hanging out
and stuff and we were like waiting for
it to like afford like video games and
shit like that.
So,
so I drew all the time and spent time
with my family and stuff and so for that
I'm grateful. I feel like that discipline
really plays into like executing ideas.
You know, I have do millions of ideas
at all times, you know, and just like,
I think a lot of people have ideas
and they just think it's, I don't,
they've been programmed to think
it's not like a table or something,
which is silly to me.
Yeah.
Well there's that Hump that you have to
get over in associating pleasure with
getting things done.
Yeah. And also I think too, it's like
people's idea of success is so warped,
you know, it's like they base it on
money or status or fame and, and,
and to be honest with you,
when I started tattooing,
I didn't even know it was a job.
I just knew it felt organic and
it felt like natural, not, not,
it didn't come to me naturally.
I worked really hard for it,
but it felt like this is where I was
supposed to be. You know, and ever,
and this is granted before
like a television show and
stuff. It was, you know,
I just came from Disneyland.
It was like if I were to have gotten
to design back then like, you know,
you don't get happy smiles and stuff,
you know,
I had so many Julia Roberts moments going
into stores. It's like, can we help you?
You know? And I'm just like, oh, like
I could buy this place. Like I bet no.
So they just immediately judge you.
That's our common theme
when I was younger. Yeah. I mean
nowadays it's so like embraced, you know,
I mean if my dad who was
super anti tattoos and it
doesn't have any or anything,
um, you know, it took 10
years of me tattooed cause I,
I started tattooing on that TV show
when not after 10 years of tattooing.
So it took a television show for
my dad to actually, um, you know,
acknowledge the fact that I wasn't
like not a loser, but you know,
like that I wasn't throwing my
life away. Then he's like, oh,
and sometimes it takes that. I don't
hold that against my dad. I mean,
I don't blame them.
Really.
Yeah.
You've influenced a lot of checks
and like how they look like you've,
you was our first one that like pop
through and boys,
Joe the first one who was like a really
hot chick who just tattooed herself the
fuck up. It's like, Whoa, this check went
for it. And, and, and, and guys were like,
I like it. I like it. And then
boom. Then there was a wave of them.
It was you.
And then it was like everywhere you look,
there's this crazy tattooed up girls.
Like the percentage of it,
I don't know what, I don't
know. I'll, I'll put a number
on it. Increase by like 30,
40,
50%.
It went from however minimal amount of
women tattooed to like one out of three
women had, have tattoos in America
and that was like back at sea. Uh,
I remember that stat when I
did the Ellen degeneres show,
which was like years ago.
That's hilarious. Do you look at
the stats? Like we're winning,
we're taking over them? No,
no, no, no, because I never, I,
well, you know, I mean, I have friends
that have no tattoos and they're like,
feel the need to get one. I'm like, I
don't know. Like, you are where you are,
you know? It's good. I mean,
I get tattooed for myself
personally. You know, it's, um,
if anything, it's kind of, it's kind of
a drag some to, I don't really feel like,
you know, always talking about my tattoos
I get when I'm going out and stuff,
but it's also a positive thing, so I
can't complain. You know? I love art, so.
Yeah. Yeah. It's,
it's a weird thing with people if either
they either have them when they don't
have them. If they don't have, they could
never imagine. Oh, can never imagined,
never imagined drunk something.
It's just a tiny forever aside girls,
they owe you big time. You blew
that, that company up. Right. Well,
that whole look, yeah,
they need a worship. You
Dude, the, the, the guy who came up with
that whole concept, but a while ago.
Do you feel weird about that?
And like that you've, I mean,
that's gotta be a strange thing
to have so much influence.
Um, you know, I think, uh, I may not have
recognized it when I first started, um,
you know, being in the public
eye or whatever, it's as,
as that until I got sober,
I think I really started recognizing
that and it became important to me.
You know, I'm pretty PG 13,
just by nature, you know,
I'm pretty squeaky clean.
I don't,
you could take my phone and go through
it and find pictures of my cat and stuff
and probably not anything
incriminating. But, um, um, I,
I like the idea of like, uh, putting that
good, good stuff out there. You know,
like all my books and everything, I, it's,
it's really easy for me to talk about
my downfalls or like my issues are not
struggles cause that sounds like a murder
or something. But like, you know, the,
the, the Shit I've experienced
it in hopes that, I dunno,
people would feel less alone because I
know what it's like to feel that way. So,
you know,
I dunno.
That's what a lot of people say about
people that are covered in tattoos.
And if you'd never,
I have two sleeves,
if you in case you think
I'm being an asshole, they,
they feel like a lot of
people don't have tattoos.
Feel like you're covering something up.
Oh yeah. I remember doctor drew and I had
a conversation about that cause he, um,
I love this book that he wrote.
Um,
and in it talked about
how tattooing is like a,
a form of narcissism, not unlike a
level of uh, oh, I think I'm awesome,
but the opposite, which is narcissism just
the same. But um, you know, like it's,
it's a reflection of what it's a on the
inside and I don't really necessarily
see it that way because that to me, yeah,
there's some tattoos that hold meaning.
Like I love my dad, I got a portrait
of my arm that's self explanatory.
But there's other stuff I like my
friends who don't know how to draw,
like tattoo me. It looks like a drunk
in three year old did something.
And I love it because it's just fun
and it's cool. And I don't really care.
You know, you let your friends
draw on you. I let them
tell to me, which is bigger,
like a bigger deal. Yeah. But I'm
done to Drew's is silly bitch.
I love him too, but he's a silly bitch.
I need to get him on the podcast.
I saw him the other day at the gas
station. Get them on, I'll get them on. I,
you know,
he's been involved in that scandal for
influencing the idea that people bought
some certain drugs off label,
like saying touting their sexual benefits
and stuff and then we'll talk crap
about marijuana or people smoke pot and
it, he'll say silly things like that.
The horribly addictive it is. And it's
all just nonsense. I don't, you know,
I haven't,
like I said earlier,
I haven't known to television and it
was 16 years in March and I'm pretty
adamant about not watching television.
Um, my point, I don't know, but, but,
but you know, I get what you're saying
that I can't tell you why you're getting,
you can't say that. You're just
not enjoying the art. He can't,
I know people love their tattoos and
love it for the person and you know,
yeah. Like I do. I of course
we all have issues and stuff.
I have no problem like wearing my
heart on my sleeve. And I mean,
I've actually gotten a lot of shit
for that, you know what I mean?
In the past and stuff with
relationships and I just don't,
I don't really live in that
world of regret or really
giving a fuck. So, you know,
I just hate absolutes like that,
like, and how you have to be the up,
you have to be this, you have to do that.
It's, it gets silly with certain things.
I mean, I think no one's perfect
either, so I feel like, you know,
I can see the goodness in everything.
Even the stuff I don't
necessarily agree with, you know,
I guess I tried to at least,
right. Yeah. Yeah. I just, I would,
I would like to look at things that way.
I would like to look at people
with tattoos and just, you know,
I don't know why anybody got him,
but I look at them and go, wow,
I hope you like it. I hope it's something
that means something. You would hope.
It's something everybody
had for whatever reason,
wants to immediately try to figure out
what was fucked up with you that made you
get to the place where you enjoy that
like totally corporate and working in a
cubicle that's miserable. And there's
like suppression of like, of creativity.
Like, man, that's such a waste
of life energy. You know,
like imagine if everybody was free to do
things like, um, as they, you know, like,
like I was talking about earlier,
people's idea of success. It's like,
imagine if you didn't,
you weren't bound by like everybody
else's idea of that, you know,
like if you could settle for a job that
paid less but you were completely happy.
I mean, my dad and I, we used to argue
about this all the time because he's like,
you know, you didn't go to
high school. And then it's
like, yeah, I know dad. I know,
but check it out.
Like you went two years of school and
you don't like what you do and you're
struggling so hard. And my dad comes from
a medical background and stuff, but um,
and I was on
my way to work every day and I walked
down like the tarnished fucking Hollywood
stars, you know, like just
walking. I'm like, oh my God,
there's like a bunch of punk rockers
there. And it's like, ah, it's just,
life is good. Like I love it. I don't, you
know, and, and if I wasn't getting paid,
I'd still be happy. There's a documentary
that Warner Herzog just put out.
It's called the happy
people a year in the taiga.
It's these people that live up in
Siberia and how happy they are.
And there's like no depression.
Everybody just does their work and
all their whole life is struggle.
Their whole life is all they live off
the land almost completely any entirely
trapping hunting. And uh, they're,
they're in fucking Siberia.
There's only one way to get there.
You have a couple of months we
could take a boat. That's it.
Otherwise you've got to get flown in.
There's no roads to get up there
and these people are happy as fuck.
They're just up there, you know, like
shooting animals, living off the land,
growing their own vegetables.
They have to work hard in the spring
and summer to prepare for the winter and
then they prepare for the
winter like smoking fish.
I mean every day no one has a job every
day they're working like securing food
for their families and storing it up so
they can make it through the next winter.
I mean,
it's amazing.
It's not really that different than
living in Hollywood and people who do that
in their own ways. It's
just, yeah, it's just more,
I feel like it's more than what that,
yeah,
it sounds so much more simple and like
less thought about like here it's like
the stress of getting to work and fighting
three hours of traffic to get to a
job that I don't respect her
love and you know, it's there,
you're still suffering or whatever for
something. You know what I mean? Well,
something happened somewhere along
the line somewhere along the way.
And Society and our culture moved
way faster than the human body did.
And all of a sudden jobs
required you to sit still.
They required you to stare
at fucking unnatural light.
They required you to enter in things
and you're fucking backwards and you're
doing it all day every day.
Like the body's not designed for that.
The body's designed to do with these
fucking people in Siberia are doing,
it's designed to go out and
kill Caribou and, and you know,
have dogs chained to trees and they
keep the bears away. I mean that's,
these guys are happy as fuck and this
is the real way we're supposed to live.
It's crazy. They hate it.
Well they don't though.
See what I'm saying is that like we all
have our little receptors I think are
set up for road to reward
us for certain experiences.
I don't think we're set up any different
than the people that lived when you had
to live like that.
So I think the only way to really not
feel lost is there's no fucking movie star
status when you're in Siberia.
There's no front of the line of the
club generated. There's no bullshit.
There's no nothing.
There's no head of 10th Planet Jiu Jitsu.
There's no standup comedian. There's
no nothing. There's get a fish.
You got to get a fish because we're
going to fucking die in the winter if you
don't, and everybody does that, but yet
they're all happy and shit. They, there's,
even when you were a kid and you like
you like thought of like where you were
like, well, we'll never, I'll never live
there. I'm never going to move there.
I'm not.
I'm never going to out of this class
and they're never going to get out of this
situation. This is where I'm at. Well,
for them it's a reality where they're
surrounded by nature and woods like there
really is no alternatives,
so they have no delusions
is no ridiculousness in
their life and the truly in
the moment living like people were
living 10,000 plus years ago. Yeah,
that's how we're supposed to live.
So we're fucking ourselves up.
If they had TV bullshit. How long do you
think it would take one generator TV?
They'd be out of there in a minute.
The kids were like,
what are we doing out
here? Yeah, going to MTV,
Kat von d would change the
way they all look mommy.
And one month they'd all want tattoos.
They'd be a make it homemade
tattoos of beaver teeth and shit.
They would start that dude the Siberia.
We were at the, uh, the
coffee place and uh,
we're having small talk with the Nice
lady behind the counter and she said, oh,
I had a house sit this weekend. It was
terrible. They didn't even have cable,
no Internet. And me and Eddie
were like, well, but we were
being serious. Whoa, whoa.
No cable. What the fuck? So what
do you use antenna? That sucks.
And then Eddie goes, well, at least he
got the Internet. And she's like, no, no,
they didn't even have the
Internet. He's, what is thought TV?
You can just get on the Internet.
These guys don't even have,
they don't even have electricity
in. They're happy. They
don't have electricity,
man.
They just don't know.
They get a little bit of gasoline that
they use for their snowmobiles and their
chainsaws and that's a wrap.
That's it.
They probably think they're bawling like
the lower class of them who lived in
the hills and there's no class man.
That's what's crazy.
They all live in the exact same houses.
They don't even use windows man.
They don't use windows because
windows are too hard to carry around.
So they build these houses at a log and
then they cut holes in the logs and put
plastic and nail plastic in place.
It bears,
bears rip them apart so often
those damn bears, I swear.
What are they going to get class anyway?
What's hard to transport?
They could bring shit. They
got of chainsaws. They did.
Then I'm making their own chain saws.
They somehow or another got chainsaws
either taking them on a boat or flown in.
Somebody gave them a few tools, but
they like make, they make boats with,
with a fucking big piece of wood.
It,
just drop it down and hollow it out and
make this canoe and let's like it's,
that's how they live every year.
It does never change and
yet their happiest fuck.
It's really weird because to us it would
be hell to the lady who works at the
coffee place, she was bumming
out that she didn't have cable.
You know these motherfuckers
are fighting them on the ski.
Those like you've never seen because
of mosquitoes are only alive for like a
couple of months. They only got a
couple months of Siberia to live.
So they go gangster Chung. It swarms like
you'll never seen anything like that.
And they don't have any raid or any
shit like that. So they have to the off,
they have to cover themselves in tar.
They make a tar with bark,
they cook the bark down to a tar and
then rub it all over their face with like
oil. Fuck that. Fuck that
Nigga. Fuck that shit.
You've never seen mosquitoes like this.
That's horror.
Well that's one of the
beautiful things about La.
Say we're not supposed to be here,
so life doesn't like it here either.
There's not that much here without
without us. Some of the much water.
There's very few bugs. Yeah, there's
very few bugs. Like in the summers in,
in the east coast, it was
fucking terrible. You know?
Especially like in, uh,
in Boston, if you lived anywhere near a
lake, anywhere near a body of water, oh,
the mosquitoes were horrendous, man. They
would fuck you up. Nothing like Siberia,
Dude. Shit. Get, they're so
happy. Yeah. But then again,
you wouldn't be happy that way. You
wouldn't be having, no, you wouldn't, not.
If you know your life now, you
love tattooing, you love, you know,
you love them to find me. I mean,
that's true. You could adapt. Yeah,
of course you can. Do you think
you could be a Siberian princess?
I don't know if I'm
wanting to be a princess,
but be up there beaver trapping
and shit. A warrior. Yeah.
That'd be cool for the first
couple of months a year. Fuck it.
We go live with them until
you realize they have no
cigarettes. You're like, shit,
I want a cigarette so bad.
You're like that for two days and someone
will give you some rolled up bullshit
that tries to claims a cigarette,
one issue of inked magazine
would destroy that culture. Oh,
anything would destroy it.
Access to
some of things would destroy it.
The idea is that it takes
the body somewhere between
10 and maybe even possibly
20,000 or more years to completely change,
like to completely change
as far as like, um, uh,
if for you to have a like a,
like a genetic response to a and to
adaptation to change to like 10,000 years
for us is not a long,
long time to a human being.
But to species it's really not that much.
So in order for things to like decide
that they're moving in a certain
directions,
then they start changing.
And that's one of the things that like
the really controversial ideas behind
autism is that autism is
not necessarily a benefit,
but that autism might be a new possible
way that the brain can operate.
You know, with some like really
high functioning autistics.
It's like what they're showing is like
even though it's coming through in a
disease and even know it,
it beings with it debilitating
social issues and shit like that.
The positive aspects of it,
like a kid that can look out a window
and then draw the whole fucking skyline.
Yeah.
That what that is is representing the
next stage of human evolution and that all
the information that we're getting
from sit in front of computers from
interacting with each other in a way that
no one has ever been able to do before.
The brain is just going,
we're just red line in that motherfucker.
Be able to buy that upgrade can
imagine that just being like, oh,
I was going to be available Bryan Hill.
It's to be a pill.
It's just going to be like, oh, we're
going to fuck up your brain a little.
Mostly most likely if you listen
to like the real futurists,
it's going to be some sort of a
hybrid between a human and a computer.
It'll be something where you'd
be long gone by then, so,
but I don't know about that unless
I'm autism pills. I don't think so.
I don't think you'll be long gone.
I think you might experience
that and I don't necessarily
think it's a bad thing.
I think everybody's worried about every
new possible technological thing as
being something that separates
us from each other or something
I'm worried about it is,
it's just seems like a lot of,
a lot of energy to waste on thinking
about. I don't know. I mean, I then again,
you know, I'm not like a big
fan of like reading fiction,
you know? I guess, I mean,
you're not a fan of fiction.
You don't, you don't even
have a television, right? No.
I mean I have like a movie
screen that can watch movies.
You watch movies but no cheese. Yes. I
like documentaries and stuff like that.
But you try to avoid
TV? No, I do avoid TV.
I don't like forced advertisement
and it don't like, um, well, no,
I don't want to complain. I just think
that I will tell you what is you're on it.
No, I mean I can, no, I come to you
could, you can get, wait you mean,
I mean I could easily,
I could more.
It's easier for me to talk shit about
like point out all the downfalls of my
television show versus anyone else.
So like in vague terms I think
that my problem with it or my,
the reason that I stay away from it,
aside from just being,
I got too many ideas that I want to do
and I don't have time but like is that I
am too sensitive. So like I, I get
like I get heartbroken by billboards.
Like seriously,
there was like a movie,
I remember there was like a movie
and had billboards everywhere.
I don't remember the movie.
It was like, you know,
Ashton Kutcher and some like hot
chick or whatever and like, and, and,
and he's like putting on
buttoning up his shirt.
She's like buttoning up and she's wearing
his shirt and she's like getting out
of bed and it says something about like
no strings attached or like friends with
benefits or some shit. And I was
like, like that's so sad to me.
Like it's like the opposite.
Like you guys just like have sex with
each other and there's no like I could
never, I, wow. And you almost
kill fried looking at a billboard.
I mean if I think about it too much.
Yeah I do.
So it's like I watch if I were to sit
there and watch these television shows
where the premise is to like,
you know,
there's a rich guy and a bunch of girls
are fighting over this guy and they're
using like their tits and ass
too as, as qualities. It's, it's,
it's disheartening. So I mean I sound
like an old lady because no you don't.
I get it. Good city. I feel that
way. Like an banded circuit city.
It's depressing to me and I get sad.
There's just an absence of true love.
And then I guess the romantic and we
get saddened by that. Same with music.
I can't listen to music. That's too, yeah,
you can definitely get affected by some
shit. Especially if you don't know.
It's common,
like any flipping through the channels,
there's some intense fucking
movies on like that you, you know,
you're just flipping through.
Like, I want Straw dogs last night.
Do you know what Straw dogs out?
I haven't seen it.
This is insane rape scene in this movie
where I turned on the movie right when
it was going on. I was like,
what fucking movie is this?
But for the rest of the night I was
all fucked up. I mean it becomes a,
I don't want to say anything
about the moment. The movie's
very good. Um, but it's,
it gets really fucking intense.
Whereas like the rest of the night it
was fucked up and I ordinarily wouldn't
have watched it,
but I didn't know what it was.
I was just pressing buttons and then boom,
it came on and fuck my head
for the rest of the night.
Yeah. And it's weird. I don't think
it's like, we just kind of like tea we,
and I think it's like people become so
desensitized and I guess that's the part
that I have a problem with.
You know, like people,
you can see it on Twitter you said on
Instagram. So every so negative in me and,
and take any opportunity
to like knock people down.
I've never been from that like
train of thought, you know,
cause my parents just raised this a lot
differently and stuff and so it like I
get like I get butthurt really easily.
That's better.
No,
you'll,
you'll attract better people that way
and you'll figure out a way to get away
from the people that
Oh yeah.
I mean it's,
it's like giving that any
values just as bad I think.
But I just want people to be nice.
That's all.
Oh,
almost all really expressive people.
Anybody who's a artistic
or very expressive,
there's always some extreme sensitivity.
And the other side of it is just,
is just, you're intense about everything.
You're probably intense about love.
You probably tense about,
yeah.
I mean that's why he cry when he seen
Ashton Kutcher thing. It's your intensity,
your, your, your you, you take shit up
to a higher level quicker than most.
Well that's probably one of the,
everything's a symbol.
And then I get sad about that.
So, yeah. But I've been sad.
I've cried during previews,
depressing movies like
good burger. What? I Dunno,
here's funny over some sad thank
you. Don't encourage them. Sorry,
I'm just doing it. How can you
say that? After all he's done it.
But you know,
then there's like those like moments of
brilliance and people are inspiring and
great and do awesome shit.
Yeah,
well that's a, that's what we
get off each other the most.
That's the most beautiful thing that
people get from each other as we, we,
you know, we were inspired by
each other. They're like, yeah,
I love going to the music because
I'm not musical. I can't do anything.
So I love going and watching cause I feel,
I feel like it, it fires me up again.
Oh, you go to musicals. No, no, no,
no, no, no, no. I'd love to see music.
I love to see people are forming,
bands perform. I love to see dem.
I love to see people do things that I
have zero skill in that I was impressed
with with our last exchange of emails
with when we were like going back and
forth on band recommendations and stuff.
Cause I had no idea that you were
into this, that kind of stuff.
Well the funny thing is he, he
emailed me and he's like, Hey,
I want to know like what are your,
what are you listening to you nowadays?
I want to get some new music. And I'm
like, oh man. Like where do you start?
Give me a genre, you know? And so that
turned me on to so many good stuff.
And I was like,
all right here,
here's like 10 and then tell me which
ones you like and then I'll know what
kinds of I'll be, you're like genius
playlist or another. Oh Wow. That's cool.
And then you're using Kat von d
for use genius playlist. I love,
she's got some great shit.
Yeah. I'm going to tell you my,
my Kat von d music story. Most people,
well, most people don't know that.
She has an amazing voice.
She can sing her ass off and she's
really shy about it. She's crazy.
Shout about it. We have the true, well
let, let me, let me tell you this.
She doesn't like talking about it. No
doubt about it. I just can't say like,
Oh yeah, it is true. We're both
working with the same producer,
which is also her best friend.
Danny is producing my stuff and he's
messing with her to musically as well.
So I'm at Danny's and we're working
on some stuff and he goes, me and uh,
me and Kat and Wes Borland
from [inaudible], he's a
guitar player for West.
It goes me and West, you're going
to do a little benefit. So kind of,
he really helped me out.
Like last minute,
I had a last minute
they put together this,
they're putting together
this song lasts minutes,
a cover and she's going to perform
at this gay benefit, right? Yeah.
It was for the, for uh, Linda
Perry's, um, evening. We
women. It's like awesome. Yeah.
So Dan is telling me and
Danny, he's like, man,
we're trying to put together the songs
because it was like less than 48 hours to
learn the song. It was like that
Bronski beat I Lebron TV and like,
and I mean I ended up just like reading
it from my iPad as I was turning until
we fucked it up.
But it was fun and it was great and stuff.
But then I think I had been recording
that night at Linda's and you were at
Danny's and I was really
excited because I had um,
cause I had like gnarly stage fright
issues like for the last year and stuff,
just whatever. And so I finally read
the balls I guess to get over them and,
and so obviously Danny is my best friend
and I'm gonna be working on music.
So I was like, Oh hey, I want
to come over. It was late.
I think it was like what,
like almost midnight or something. Yeah,
me and Danny are working on a set that,
and Linda Perry,
for those who don't know,
she was the lead singer for four non
blondes. She produced pinks second album,
which went fucking skyrocket.
So Linda Perry is a massive,
like Christina Aguilera to the big APP.
You're so beautiful.
She did all the first
thing I want to hear this
Linda Paris,
right, right. Yeah. So
she's working with cat now.
They're writing some shit together.
I'm at Danny's, she's all excited.
Quarter a song. They brought it over
and then Dan, he's like, text me.
Is it cool if Eddie Bravo is, I'm
like, yeah, I don't care. I've just,
just don't say anything about it.
And then,
but of course I had to be in
the other room cause I was like,
I'm not going to sit there and go,
oh,
you know how and where do you
think or whatever. But yeah,
she had to go to the next room.
It's just like vocal.
There wasn't like a produce
track or anything. And then,
um, Danny was all stoked,
but he, he texts me, he's
like, man, he's still talking
about it. He liked, loved it.
Then I'm like, aw, that makes me,
has that. Danny said, yeah. So what,
what ended up have you and told the story.
I've told this story a bunch
cause like the next day at school
do you can't tell you. Most
of you guys don't know this,
but I was so impressed with
her voice and the actual song,
her and Linda Perry together. I feel with
the right marketing. Of course it could.
It could. It could. It could.
I think it could be huge. Could it
be bigger than Paris Hilton? Single.
I like that song a lot.
I bet you did.
Did she get that shit tattooed on your
Dick and I will. Anyways, the song,
the song they burn,
Linda Perry did together.
The first one that she bought
over is amazing. What's it called?
I'm talking about it yet. It's too, it's,
you can't talk about it so she's
just trying to send you hit.
The bottom line is she's actually a
great singer. Her voice is amazing.
When I see your artwork, I think you'd
be good at anything you wanted to be.
You'd be amazing
at you if you can.
If you can draw that well,
I mean that's like some really high level
shit. You could do that with anything.
I really believe that.
I believe that with anybody
who's super awesome and anything.
How many bad tattoos do you see a day of
people just coming in with? Like, I mean,
do you, have you, have you ever
seen one that you're just like, wow,
that's the worst tattoo I've ever,
well, I mean it's a, there's such
a big difference in like, um,
like personal preference versus
technical aspect of things. So like,
I mean, there's some stuff that's
not necessarily technically it's a,
it's like everything else,
like music,
it's like technically might
not be the best singer,
but the Christmas behind it and, you
know, blah, blah, blah. I mean, well,
there's that style that, um, the, the,
the what, what was the teacher Ed Hardy,
that Ed hardy sort of style
fit 1950s traditional stuff,
which not that artistic, but that's all it
is. A Sky like that loner art, you know,
and I didn't understand
it for a long time.
My ex husband was like really into doing
that kind of artwork and he's really
great at it. There's an
art behind the, you know,
I personally am not inclined to
do that kind of stuff, but I,
but I appreciate it for what it is.
So I don't know what I mean.
I think I see a lot of great
ideas, you know, and people often,
and then you just see kind of
a poor execution or, or, uh,
an inexperienced execution as it.
But yeah, I mean, I don't know.
I'd see so many amazing things now that
like, blow me out of the water. It's like,
fuck, there's so many
great artists nowadays. So
I'm permanently scarred from ever getting
a tattoo again because of my tattoo.
Because it was a free tattoo. Was
somebody practicing for their first time?
It took seven hours. You should
have take one hour. God, I remember.
I used to be that slow too. Yeah. And then
I found out it's not even supposed to,
it's like supposed to be an r for my
last name and I found out it means
waterfalls and now,
so now it's like the ugliest tattoo
ever with this Chinese letter.
That means waterfalls, but it's
probably smiling. Covered up easy. Yeah.
That's great. Yeah. You just
get the shit lasered off son.
They could do that pretty easy now.
Especially like um, like it's not red.
Red is apparently the most difficult.
Coke Cola.
Yeah, it's got red. It's got
red in it. Have you got oh is
it? Yeah, it does it. Yeah.
They could work that right.
Easiest to count flu.
I thought that was blue for some reason.
It's written with the red is
the easiest to get out. Yeah,
red and black and then purples and greens.
I think Greens are a little harder but
it all depends on like how have you done
it yet? Have you done the
lasering off anything? Yeah,
these are a couple of like
this whole arm lasered.
It used to be I got this
tattoo and I was like 15 or 16.
It was like the New York dolls,
like cowgirl with a gun and then
there's like a flag coming out of his,
his bang and at the time I thought
it was cool. I'm like, man,
I have the Word Bang on my arm. Get rid
of it. That's better than waterfall.
How long did it take? Well with like
laser, you have to go for sessions.
It's like super painful and
stuff, but more painful than
tattooing. Fuck yeah. Wow.
Well I'm a woosie so I dunno, I can't
handle it. Did you just, yeah. Yeah.
You have tattoos all over your body and
you're telling me that you're woman ask
anybody at my short like 15 minutes,
then I tap out like candy.
Those are all 15 minutes
after. No, this was all,
a lot of them was under the
influence of alcohol. So easier.
But now that like back the day
does a Taser easier?
Remember that one time where I
drank too much or do I remember
you saying that?
It's hilarious cause I can just go
through a Rolodex in my head of any moment
that sentence could apply to I,
he wrote a blog about my
alcohol problem. No, no,
I don't have an alcohol.
I'm not an alcoholic,
but I will drink a lot on special
occasions and when I pass a certain point,
the Indian comes out as Joey Dia says.
And when the Indian comes out, for sure,
I'm not going to remember
any of the night. He's he
blacks out. It's like, oh no.
There's like, Ooh, I love you man.
He's a great, he's a great guy.
The problem is he completely checks out
and he doesn't know where he is and he's,
I mean literally is like a third of a
mind controlled by like a demon from
another galaxy.
One Third Eddie and two thirds,
some a demonic alcohol sucking demon
from another planet, but weird.
But you can always like, oh no, no, never
even, I don't mean that. I mean demonic.
I mean like possessed by the alcohol,
just wandering around it.
He doesn't know what happens until the
next day when he sobers up and you have
to tell them what happens.
Like I, I can't, I,
I've had to like get his hotel door
opened by security banging door in Germany
when we were supposed to leave bang on
his door. Finally the door opens. Okay,
we get the door open.
Eddie is lying in bed with
his cowboy boots on and the
light is on and the smile,
the light is on.
It's completely,
I just completely out cold Eddie.
We got to go to the fucking
airport. He's like, what's up?
He just looks at me and the security.
I was, hey, what's up? Yeah.
Like I'm trying to find it out.
It was the worst story.
That's not even the worst story.
The car one car one is the worst.
I talked to him,
it was like I was having breakfast,
it was like seven o'clock in the morning
and the car was going to come at nine
and he calls me while we were having
breakfast. He still fucked up. I mean,
he is fucked up,
was to drink all night and walk onto
the airplane and then sleep all the way
back to like stay up all
night. So, so, uh, you know,
I go, uh, are you fucked up? Did you
stay up on, I said, yeah, fuck yeah man,
I'm a power through. I will
power through. And so I go, okay,
well we're leaving at eight
30. All right, you gotta,
you gotta be down there for the car at
eight 30. No, no problem. No problem.
So I eat breakfast. An hour
and a half later I go out
for, you know, wait for him.
I don't want him, you know, I want to have
sitting here 10 minutes later I'm like,
okay, what the fuck is going
on? So I talked to the guy
was the valet. I go, Hey,
is my car here? And the guy says, what's
your name? I should Rogan. He goes, oh,
Rogan already left. I go, no,
no, no. Rogan is me. He goes,
no Rogan already left. I go,
what did he look like? Yeah. He said,
well, he had long hair at the time,
so long hair, tattoos. I'm
like, that motherfucker.
So I called him up and first of all,
he answers the phone that just hangs up.
It's like, realize this car and
then then the phone, Wah, Wah.
I didn't even know what he did. Wake up
and I see you. It's Joe calling. I'm like,
what? I go, what's up? He goes,
you took my car and I hung up and I were
on the Autobahn and I tell the drag of,
where are we going? Let's we'll go
to the airport. I'm like, Oh shit.
Then he keeps calling him that. That was
the autobon. I don't know what it was,
but we're flying us a regular, Huh?
Well, it sounds like a good time. Yeah.
It was handed to us. Yes. So
then I woke up and I kept cards,
sending it to my message,
a am I answering service or whatever,
and I had to figure out what the hell was
going on. And then I finally answered.
He's so fucking mad. I'm like, Holy Shit.
I'm sorry. I have no idea what happened.
I just woke up in the back of the car.
I don't remember the whole night.
I must have passed and just just jumped
in, jumped in his car. This was like,
it's like total,
like if Eddie,
there's a certain number of drinks where
he gets over will just disappear and
he's gone. The, the Aubrey
story, the Texas was,
I brought that up. I wasn't, I was
just going to bring up the end.
He would also have to know,
you know what else I found out?
I found out my cat in
Japanese means waterfalls,
and then I'm like thinking
something's fucked up with waterfall.
Hecky in Japanese means waterfalls.
I found out the other day then you should,
you should be celebrating your tattoo.
I didn't want to go chasing waterfalls
this mind for some no. Need to know why.
What's that song from? What was that?
Bam, Tlc. TLC. There was a sweet song.
I'm never going to walk in the ocean
cause I might come out of Blob. Brian,
you need to go outside and get some air.
So what are your plans for your music?
What's the plan? Well, you know, I've it,
the coolest thing I think with Linda
is like, we're just kind of, we're,
we're moving forward without any,
uh,
deadlines. No, it was on the deadlines.
We have goals obviously, but it's a,
you know, like by summertime I think it
should be done out, which is exciting.
But I think it's like we
not really congesting our
thoughts with anything right
now. We're just writing music
without outside voices. No
reference. Just, you know.
So you said you got
over your stage fright,
you're going to start doing live
performances. Oh, Yay. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm putting a band together. Yeah. Yeah.
You're going to go on tour? Yeah. Yeah.
Holy Shit. Wow. She's going to be a rock
star watch. You're going to be a rockstar.
The term is so weird to me.
It seems like you can sneak it through
from the back door just from just from
having talent and being on TV.
It's like you just went through.
I Dunno.
I just,
I want to do everything with even
small things with a lot of quality.
And so I think like with the music stuff,
I just want to make it as, you know, uh,
as good as possible for lack of a
better description. But, um, yeah,
so I think people will probably be
pleasantly surprised in the sense that
they're expecting me to fail
as usual. So, yeah, I like it.
People are expecting you to fail. I think
people always expect you to feel like,
you know, I think grilling. Yeah. I
mean other than your friends, Avi,
I'm talking about like,
you know, yeah, I think so.
Especially me. Cause I was on TV,
so it's like, oh, you're just
doing the, that's definitely true.
But you have some success.
They want it to be at.
It's hard to get into music after you
already famous with for something
else. It's tough. Yeah. So, oh, hello.
Has Anybody ever done it?
Well, Jamie Foxx, Steve Martin,
sort of Steve Martin is bands pretty,
pretty big for a certain kind of music.
Oh, he does like just playing music shows,
right? Yeah. Yeah, he does.
He plays the Banjo and stuff.
A bunch of like, you know,
it's a certain style of music, but he's
doing six. He's successful in that,
you know. Hmm. Anybody Audie
Murphy. Oh, that's right.
And that's kind of like
what my stuff sounds like.
What kind of shit to you sound like?
What does it,
Linda and I both have like tried figuring
it out and the dark Sarah McLaughlin
kind of stopped it.
Don't say that kind of stuff.
I could never compare myself to
anybody, but uh, yeah, no, it's just,
she just calls it, uh, uh,
powerfully put that x, which is,
which is good power,
powerfully put that egg.
I think it's tragic and romantic,
but there's like elements of classical
music and and stuff and some electronic
element. There won't be any show cro
type. All I want to do is have some fun.
You don't know that song.
[inaudible] stuff and listen,
we're so mainly we take in the other
direction. We're not scared to talk.
Sheryl crow. That's a great
song. It's a great fucking song.
You don't like that kind of
music? I just don't, I don't know.
What do you listen to personally?
Oh Man. Kent, Kent, Kansas.
One of my favorite bands was a Swedish
tea. I like a lot of Scandinavian music.
I like a lot of metal and I like a
lot of love, Depeche mode in the cure,
shit like that. So a lot of obscure
shit that people wouldn't be aware of.
And then a lot of like classic
shit like Susie and the banshees.
I don't even listen to anything that's
made before 1980 anymore of giving black
sabbath black. I listened, I
listened to some black keys.
That's the only modern
shit I'll listen to.
And then everything else is old stuff.
I've been listening.
He's like Allman brothers. Oh,
okay. I see what you're saying.
I said before, sorry, anything
after 1980 I'm like done. I'm done.
Except the black keys.
The black keys seem to have kept the
soul like honey and honey, honey. Yeah,
that's right there. My
friends. Oh yeah, sure.
I go to some of the best shit ever.
But I mean like modern bands that like
you hear on the radio that are like big
hits. Like I can't get into, I
couldn't even tell you supermarket.
Every now and then,
that's the only time I hear music.
I'm just shopping and I'm like, what
the fuck is this? Is this something new?
Just some weird,
no,
it would be some weird
fucking auto tuned bullshit.
And it's repeating itself over and over
again. And I'm like, is this the new shit?
Is this, is this like, is
this popular right now?
I feel like I'm some dude who's like an
outlier like comes into town every now
and then to find out what the folks
are up to. That's what it feels like.
And as I get older and older,
it becomes more and more apparent.
I can understand like especially like,
I mean I like some like pop music I guess,
but I, it's, it's,
it's hard for me to wrap my
mind around certain things.
Like how does that resonate with
people? Because for me, I'm always,
I love poetry and I love things that
are so much more profound and uh,
and I think people are hungry
for that. You know? I think like,
even though like a lot of stuff that's
like really big right now is very
superficial and whatever. But like I
feel like there's definitely like, um,
I think people are hurting and they
want to relate somehow. So I don't know.
Well, I, yeah, I definitely think that,
but I also think there's
like a lot of music to it.
Some people just aren't even aware of.
Of course,
there's a lot of young kids today that
don't even know what a whole lot of love
sounds like when you hear it through
like really good speakers. Yeah. But the,
the day man
driving down a Hollywood and I seen these
awesome fucking metal heads and they
were like,
Karen skateboards is like young kids.
And they had like one at like a death
shirt on and then we had like a motor head
shirt on and I was just like,
they literally rolled my window down and
my friend Allison was and I'm like, Hey,
I love you guys. And they
were like, I love you too.
Fucking long hair
does metal will never die. So cool. Yeah.
I thought metal was gone in the 80s I
thought I should do like obscure black
metal
stuff that's like, you know
it's, I dunno, it's cool.
It'll will never die.
It won't.
That feeling will never die
because there's always going
to be shitty parenting.
You're never going to get rid of metal
because you're never going to make people
become good parents. You're always
going to have people just up. Fuck yeah,
they just want to pound on the wall,
fucking scream and curse
their circumstances and turn
cross is upside down. Yeah.
You're always going to
have shitty parenting,
so you're always gonna have back it.
All that shit.
I bet that shit is on a computer. I
wrote Satanic lyrics like every song had.
It either had to be about when I was
in 14 1516 all the songs I wrote were
nuclear war,
anti religion,
abs, demons, killing priests, love
songs. Nothing about Lo. No, no,
not until like I was 19 or it's in
your defense though, when we were kids,
we were growing up. You
know, we're older than you.
Probably don't recognize that
Soviet Union threat feeling.
Did you ever have that threat when you
were a kid? Did you ever feel that? See,
when we,
when Eddie and I grew up,
we were really worried that we're going
to get an a nuclear war with the Soviet
Union. Everybody, oh yeah, Brad, bro,
everybody did so close.
So close.
Dinosaurs roamed the earth. How
dare you look. It's possible today.
But back then it was,
it was not just possible.
It seemed probable seventies late
seventies late seventies early eighties
everybody thought we were
going to war with Russia.
That was a fact until Ronald
Reagan and Chernobyl affected,
effectively bankrupted the Soviet Union.
That's one of the big
things that brought it down.
But when the Soviet Union fell apart,
then everybody took a deep breath
and relax. But until that happened,
there was always this constant thread
that they were going to take a solo war
three were going to go. Yeah, they
were great. They were in Cuba.
I mean they were 90 miles from our
border setting up missile silos.
I mean there was a lot
of shit that went down during
the Kennedy administration,
so there was that feeling as,
especially as technology increased,
and then there was that star wars program
that came on when they were developing
these fucking things to shoot
missiles out of the sky.
They'd be like satellites
that were launched up with
lasers to zap missiles at a
sky.
That's like a significant part of the
budget and significant part of like what
Ronald Reagan was talking about when
they were talking about national defense.
So we were worried about going to war
with Russia. It was constant work, kids,
very popular song topic.
It seems fucked up, right?
It doesn't even make sense to you. It
was a band called nuclear assault is bad.
The song's called nuclear death, nuclear
death. Just nuclear Dick Suck. Yeah.
Nuclear Wild. Oh, there's a crazy,
I'll have new holocaust off
to put it up later. Did you,
have you seen that video Brian, that the
Holocaust survivor or excuse me, the um,
uh, the Hiroshima survivor
made, he made a, a cartoon.
You got to pull it up. Um, I forget
the guy's name something. Ben,
is he going to put it
sad? Oh, it's crazy. Well,
it's a cartoon that was written by a
survivor from Hiroshima and it depicting
how it was like, what the experience
was like for the people on the ground.
It's fucked up man.
Cause even though it's just a cartoon,
I mean just to watch it when, uh, after
the, he can't handle it, you know,
when to wash in front of us.
The less I know better about really
bad sometimes I dunno, I'll get sad.
It's kind of crazy.
And there's like 10 different countries
or more that has nuclear weapons. I mean,
how many have them? Seven? I don't know.
You just taking guesses over there. So,
yeah, I mean, and then we know Pakistan,
India, the UK, certainly, you know,
in the Korean War,
we don't think 18 Korean cities disappear.
We did 18 that's why they fucking
hate us, man. They're like, no more,
no more of this bullshit. They just shut
the shut themselves off from the world.
Can you imagine that 18 cities
disappear and it was no nuclear.
It was all like what? Hydrogen bombs
and Shannon, I dunno the bombs they is,
but they made 18 they leveled 18
cities in Korea during the Korean War.
She's crying. Shit, we don't, they
don't talk about that too much. Yeah.
Wrap your head around that.
Try thinking about 18 American
cities just disappearing. Yeah. Yeah.
It's the whole game
changed when you can fly,
when you can fly and shoot shit from
the sky. That's the game changer.
And it all happened all at once.
Fly,
shoot things from the sky and then
almost right after that nuclear bombs,
it's pretty nutty when you think about
that because there was no fucking airport
or airplane wars just a
hundred years ago in the,
in the early 19 hundreds were there.
They weren't fucking flying everywhere
and dropping bombs on each other.
They started doing that in the 30s and
the forties that's when like they started
getting better at rocketry and then boom,
47 nuclear bomb, complete game changer.
The whole thing takes less than a
hundred years to go from the airplane.
Being fucking invented to dropping nuclear
bombs on people is a hundred years.
That's nuts. Have you ever tatted a
nuclear missile? I even thought of that.
Yeah,
I think I have. I've really never
even thought of that until just now.
That is a crazy number that
the invention of the airplane,
it goes invention of the airplane all
the way to nuclear bombs and it's in less
than a hundred years.
So essentially one lifetime we go from
people stuck on the ground or in boats to
someone who could drop a fucking nuclear
bomb on your country. That's amazing.
What a fucking weird
jump in history that is.
That might be the biggest jump in
history that's ever been recorded. That,
and I never even thought
about it. And there's nowhere
to go. Is there? Oh, I mean,
I went crazy.
We were crazy.
Knowing where to go and move into Finland,
Finland, a lot of death metal there.
What do you love about them and it's
easier to go to Alaska probably isn't so
much cooler.
Alaska is gorgeous though.
We can make Alaska cool chef to
have more cool people move up there.
You're friends with the
singer from him, right? Yeah.
It's totally into that mother or that
there. Are they from Finland? Finnish.
They're like a, it's almost like
a satanic love metal band. Right?
How would you describe him? It
means his infernal majesty. Oh Geez.
Jesus Christ.
Someone needs to hold that Duke down.
[inaudible] I think it
was taken from my gun.
Hold that down and make him take his
pills. He spotted all over my couch.
Poppy metal, like satanic. Love suicide.
That's crazy. Yeah. Get
them to do hill sprints.
Maybe a sandbag workout. Be Good. Dig
a hole for today. I want you to be,
I want you to be happy.
You're alive.
I want you to dig a hole
and then when you're done,
when we can give you a cold drink,
I'm going to feel awesome.
That's not bad. Why Finland?
Why would you escape to Finland?
Finland, Ace, go there once a year.
If the shit hit the fan in America.
Is that what you would do?
I would say it's like there's
not really anywhere to go really.
What do you think about it?
I think Canada is and move.
At least you would find out what the
fuck is going on for a little bit.
Maybe a couple of years of safety
before you had escape to an article.
Back to the Siberians. Like do they
even know about it? No. I'm guess what?
They're just happy. They are happy,
but you wouldn't be happy doing it.
You mean you say you might be adaptive,
but man, you would remember the internet,
you'd remember driving
around your bad ass.
Carla's favorite songs on
my book tour last year,
halfway through my house burned
down and demolished. You know,
just gone down the street from
Danny and I remember I went,
I went on the rest of the book tour,
you know,
it was like a month or two after and went
through Canada and I just didn't tell
anybody. Just kind of,
you know, hey, I'm here.
And I literally had like what
I was wearing and that was it.
And then when I came back, you know, I
had told cat the other cat, my assistant,
like, I don't really want anything when
I get back, I'm just going to live at,
I have a gallery next door to my tattoo
shop, it's like an gallery. And we
had like an upstairs area
that was for stock, you know,
and like probably the size of your
bathroom or something. And like she,
she went and got like a air mattress
from target, which I was like, oh no,
it's too much. It's too much, you
know? But it was so weird having to,
or it's too much. Yeah. It just, it was,
it was easier to just being as
simple as possible, you know?
And you don't even want to
air mattress, you're going,
oh, sure. Got It. So I got it.
So then I, I slept on an air mattress
and uh, yeah, it was, it was fun.
It was just like an exercise for
you, like letting things go and, no,
I mean I didn't,
I never struggled with it like the
from the minute I got the news, but um,
but I mean I was in a clear place
even when I say exercise,
I don't mean necessarily like a strain,
but like a direct path that you chose
to take a direct path of a minimum
minimalist.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And let me
know. I've done it like in other ways too.
It's not a matter of depriving myself of
punishing myself, you know, like, right.
I was like celibate for
a year. Like, oh Geez.
Oh my God. I'm glad for that.
I'm just saying it's
like being as he leaves,
he's going to go beat off.
No.
Oh, you don't know him. He's crazy.
He's quick with it to be back in
before we even need them. Yeah.
That's ridiculous.
I love how we had it when I was at the
time they were like, or like on purpose.
I'm like,
well, first of all, I think that's
way easier for a woman to do.
Not just physically but psychologically
cause there's more dickhead dude's a
dickhead. Dudes are dangerous. Whereas
girls that are paying the assay data,
they're not,
they're very rarely dangerous.
It's not like the weird
feeling of intimidation.
Much more emotional and annoying. If
they can get emotional, that's for sure.
But it's not a, it's not like, like
you, you've been beat up or anything.
Like I know women who've been hit by
men and then they're done with men for
years. I mean that, that
makes sense though to me.
Whereas a guy taking a year off a sec
am I wasn't,
you can't find a nice check.
It wasn't about being reactive like
to something like, well I got hurt.
It was just more as making a
conscious decision at the time match.
If you had just like one
year yeast infection,
that was our mother wouldn't even go out.
Daddy's not even pay attention.
I know we've looked everybody we lost.
We lost you. Totally, man.
No, but you know, it was just, it's just
like, uh, I dunno. Celibacy bores me.
Yeah. It just shows like he
just checked out totally.
He's thinking of his new songs,
working on working on Jujitsu moves,
naughty show thing. As I've been looking
at that girl's boob this entire, yeah.
Pretty Nice, right? It's pretty
nice for Monica. I'm a mannequin.
It's about as hot as it gets.
She's pretty sexy. She's Brian's.
All this stuff is Brian's. This
has nothing to do with me. I, uh,
I don't want to be judged by this.
He's a silly guy.
He's got a lot of weird shit really leave
because I said no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
He just has to probably smoke a cigarette
or something. Oh, he's an odd duck.
But we make an interesting combination.
It's good. He's just trained fucking dude.
It's hard finding someone that's strange,
that also is kind of funny
and knows how to run things.
So we've got a weird little
relationship. Me and that guy. Yeah.
But going back to the Siberians like that,
what about nuclear war?
We're going to pass right on with that.
I think I'm just fucking, I think a
barrier. It's like we were saying,
I think they're only happy because they
don't know about all the groovy shit.
They don't know about iPhone.
Iphone five iPhone five is
going to be out in a week.
They didn't know about that shit. I
never drove. I never drove it. Yeah. See,
you're all excited.
You're thinking,
I'm going to get my assistant to go get
me one. You know, fucking Siberian dude's.
They'd never drove a nice car.
Never listened to a good stereo.
They're only the only think they're
happy about and they're chasing down beat
pelts. That shit's ridiculous. I
think it can be way more happy today,
like in a way higher peaky or sort of a
way, but there's a lot of crashes today.
There's a lot of,
what does it all mean?
But then there's like the most awesome
time because we're not ready for that yet.
It's too much work. Well, it's an amazing
amount of work. The whole species,
it's that and they're also busy.
You know,
people have to feed themselves and pay
their bills and you get caught up in that
sort of a work cycle where you're doing
something with your time every day just
in order to stay alive.
And it's real hard to get on another
path once you're on that path because you
sort of bad habits, I guess,
right? It's not even bad habits.
It's almost just necessity.
If you want to get by in life and
you're a person who you know, you,
you have a degree and then all of a
sudden you have a job and then all of a
sudden you have a mortgage and you have
a family or whatever the fuck it is that
you have. Is it x, Y, or z the beginning,
or is it the full morning Mani?
What?
What do you have that's holding you back?
But when you get to a certain point,
when you've accumulated like a mortgage
and accumulated a car lease and
insurance and all this different shit
that you have to pay for constantly,
it's very, very hard to break
free and get your shit together.
It's very hard to do what
you're doing right now.
You got on the right path from you on
this like hell bent for leather thing.
Like it's either gonna work or it's not
going to work, but it's pretty good. Boom.
It just, you just went out there and it
worked. It worked fantastic and amazing.
But the reality is for a lot of people
when they got on the wrong track and then
they got to change tracks,
that's when shit gets hard.
The key is you got to get on
that right track from the get go.
Like doing repair work
on your life. No, no.
Back and the track. I think you
think so? I think you can always,
if you're willing to just go for it.
Most people are not really financially
able to do that. It's too hard.
It's too hard.
If you have obligations,
it'd be hard to live a life that was
dictated by it. I guess financials.
Yeah. Sucks. It's nothing ever gets done
that way, you know, especially creatively.
That's like the worst possible reason
you could be creating art as like just
thinking I'm gonna get paid.
Just just make you know all
your illustrations to be
about how much money can I
make off of this? I wouldn't even work.
No, they've come out clunky and shit.
And insincere hat.
Yeah,
like music or bad comic book artists.
Right.
Why does he laugh? What I'm talking
about? You don't even have your own mind.
Could I have some comic book artists?
Yeah.
Do you remember when you were a kid and
you'd get comic books and every now and
then some new idiot was like
drawing the hall, you know,
like what is this guy doing?
Like the hulk doesn't even look like,
I thought it was worse when like they,
they like I remember Spiderman when used
to draw it and it was like really cool.
And then I guess McFarland one need to
like leave or whatever and do his own
thing. So they found somebody, they
just copied his own style mcfarlane.
The spawn guy? Yeah. Who wanted to do
well, we got to get Michael Jai white
in here. Man I got to it. Yeah, I got a,
I think I have his number, but
let me check it with you. Yeah,
make sure it's the same one. I ran
into him at a pool hall recently. Yeah,
he'd be great on that. I love
that dude. And he was spawn,
if you don't know who that
was, that movie, he played Spa,
which is a fucking bad ass movie,
but those spawn comic books are
a perfect example of, it's like,
that's so outside the box,
like in comparison to like the shit
that was around just in the 1950s of the
1960s the really dark
storylines and insane artwork.
Now that guy, that guy did some wild
shit and then it just went away.
Whatever happened. That dude, I love it.
She's going to get, well, I'm sure
the guy's rich as fuck. I mean,
I think if he's gone away,
it's on purpose. You know?
I don't think it's an awe.
Yeah. Do you know what I'm talking
about? The guy who made spawn,
did you ever see the spawn comics
topic? We'll see. It's all before
your time. Yeah, no, I know. It's,
do you read comics? Um, I
like Terry and the pirates.
You're in it.
You're in Tony Hawk's video game,
aren't you guys are unlockable character
Hawker gave me an ass cause I don't
have an asset and I was like,
I remember they sent me like the,
the CGI whatever thing and it's like,
because you go in and they do a little
scan thing or whatever and I remember
going like, Whoa, you guys give me
like a [inaudible]. That's good.
I usually played as your character
because I like playing girl characters for
some reason. Yeah. They gave me like my
wristband. My hair is all ran and like,
it's cool. You played me that they had
that skateboard. Where'd you stepped on?
I didn't know. It wasn't my
favorite Tony Hawk game, but it was,
that was cool seeing I and
oh man. That's awesome. Yeah,
there's a weird emotional connection when
you tattoo someone for like you're on
them for life, you know? I know. Like
for Eddie mean that that thing is,
that's a very important to him.
He's talked about meet tears up
when he talks about his grandmother.
What is that like for you to have all
these people running around there,
that you have this intense emotional
connection with something that you've
created on their body?
Oh man, it's awesome. I
remember one time I was, um,
driving to work and this guy was crossing
the street and I just, he's really,
really tall.
And I remember he looked
like a businessman with a
button up shirt and he's just
walking across the street and
have that kind of curly hair.
And I was like staring at him like,
I don't want that guy's deal is,
you know what I mean? Like what does he
do? And I can totally dry him. He has,
I was like interesting facial features.
And then I go into tattoo that day and
he was my appointment and I tattooed him.
And it was the most,
it was the most intense story of like
living in fear and regret and just making
closure with all these, with, with death,
which is I think one of the harder
subjects I think for people. And, um,
and then I remember being done with it
and driving back home and seeing him
cross the street again to go to where
his car was parked and I was like, oh,
it's like every person could be that
guy as I just always think about that
people, especially people who piss me off
or annoy me or whatever am I was like,
ah, like you just don't know. You know?
So it's, it's a cool connection. I think
you might be the crazy link to the
other dimension. It might be you,
it might've been your magic that you
used on Eddie there. That's ridiculous.
You're connected to another
of course. Synchronicity like
that. Yeah, all the time.
That's so bizarre.
You tattooed you to talk into the mic,
Bro. You covered a tattoo on site.
You talked about this before in a
different interview where you've covered a
tattoo of a dude on his dick.
Right.
We're addicted. It was so funny
because I think when the, it's true,
when I first got on TV,
you know,
like they always ask you like the first
like elementary questions. It's like,
what was your first tattoo with
the weirdest? How do you didn't,
they're always like pussy foot
around like that question. Like,
so have you ever tattooed, you know, like
a weird area. I'm just like, just say it,
you know, but whole have you done
by home? Oh that's very recent.
Girls are starting to do the button.
We'll talk to us. No, that's awful.
That's awful. Yeah. I mean that's like
sacred ground. No, it's physically uh,
you know,
take all the funny stuff.
But it's like physically a
very unhealthy thing to do.
Like the amount of toxins
and whatever. But anyways,
maybe wipe, oh, so the actual,
the, the, the more sensitive tissue. It
probably give you hemorrhoids immediately,
I would imagine. You know, he was going to
have problems, dude. And then, you know,
that area's really hard to keep
clean for some reason. You know,
I would have to go with a
doctor drew one on this.
Yeah. I would think drew
might be right about assholes
out there.
Are you crazy pitches of Kat von D
is disgusting with asshole tattoos.
That's just attention seeking and there's
no art aspect behind that. Well maybe
beautiful job they made
me, it's like, you know,
some roses in the center of them all
scrunchy and shit and maybe it's just done
to be like the most amazing rose.
Like your asshole looks like a row
now for the coq one.
Did you have to have it hard the whole
time when you're tattooing it or do you
know what I mean?
Like when you were talking to him,
a woman,
you shouldn't make that jerk off
and I say it hard. You were,
you were actually doing that.
I can explain this situation
because it sounds so much more
perverted than it was. But like it was,
there's a guy who, um, you know,
I had been through some times and had
gotten a lot of ghetto gang tattoos and
stuff at all, like homemade,
like tad, you know,
the guitar string tattoo collection yet.
And so we went through over years
and redid all of them, you know,
and he had all these brand new tattoos,
I'm covered and improved or whatever.
And then I remember, I mean,
we became, I become friends,
friends with all my clients, cause
you spend such intimate mo like times,
like it's like three hours of intense.
We're not talking about like a butthole
tattoos are like talking about like,
you know, life and death and stuff and, or
whatever we talk about. And, um, I always,
I'm always so heavy. I hate
that. Um, but uh, he was cool.
And then he came to me very respectfully
with his wife and was like, you know,
I have this one tattoo and now
that I'm remarried and stuff,
no longer with Linda and like,
um, I was just, you know,
I understand if you don't want to do
it, it's fine. But it's just, you know,
it kind of bothers them.
And she was like, name on the
deck. The word Linda. Yeah. Linda.
Linda is no,
said La. No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
What did you change it to?
No. So he comes, I'm like,
yeah man, it's cool. You know,
and so like he can't, he comes with his
wife. No, he goes with his wife and um,
and so I was like, yeah, you
know, like I'll put up like
the partitioners you know,
that you see at the hospital and stuff
so that others can watch or whatever.
And No, you don't get an erection
during that time. Uh, I don't think you,
unless you're willing to spread
it out like a butterfly though.
I had him lay down and then he whips
this tremendous thing. It's so crazy.
Like it was like, Oh, why? And
a apostrophe s it was like,
wow.
Hours and hours,
apostrophe s Linda's hours
and hours of tattooing.
And I was just basically saying it was
quite a large tattoo cause large penis.
You took your time on it as well,
just to clarify the penis and
the tattoo or both large. Yeah.
I mean it would be like you talking
to an ob Gyn about, you know, uh,
eight inches. She, you know, you,
it might've been like talking to an ob
Gyn to a dude who's got a girl touching
his penis, even under such,
in auspicious circumstances.
And there's like hovering over, you know,
he's whatever. And it's not that way.
I mean, it's like, oh, that's
so silly. It's always that
way. There's not 90% of it.
Maybe only 10% that way, but 10%
is that way. They're probably gone.
You go to your doctor and he touches your
week. My doctor doesn't look like you.
I, my doctor looked like you and touched
my penis. I'm sure I'd have a problem.
Yeah, I might have to beat off before
it got to the office to have it. You
wouldn't want to see it that way. He
does that. Oh my God, you're so crazy,
but why don't you go online and look
up doctor, doctor porn like doctor,
the female doctors who make out
with the men and have sex with me.
I know what you need. You don't
need medicine. You need sugar.
All of those that don't say no.
It's not sad. It's just reality.
It's nothing wrong with that. Dude's
reality's very sad. It's not sad.
Dudes would be massively
attracted to this idea that a,
a beautiful doctor is going to get
intimate with them. I'm not going to get,
but even just touching their
intimate parts in some sort of a, uh,
a doctor sort of a thing.
Like, so what's wrong with your penis,
Johnny? I brought this up. I apologize.
Don't be mad at me for all of them.
Well,
all I'm saying is you're a
beautiful woman and I were a doctor.
A certain amount of,
of your patients would most certainly
love it if you examine their penis.
You know what?
I don't think it's that way
much anymore in mind. You that this, I
did that tattoo when I was like, you know,
I dunno, like 19. Right
when you were even hotter. Oh, thanks. Oh,
he's retarded today.
Jesus Christ can help your point.
It doesn't help your point.
It was when I was 17.
Like that makes it better.
She's drunk back then and I was
totally out of shape versus now. Yeah.
What you're saying, you're
saying she looks worse? No,
I'm just so I can remember him saying
that. I've never seen that to a girl.
I wasn't saying that. Okay, so I have
Polish. So what did you turn it in?
I was trying to be funny
and sad at the time.
He just wanted to get the
Linda's [inaudible] apostrophe
s like Linda's Dick.
Wow. She's, this is Linda's. If
not anymore. Linda is still alive.
Fuck yet she's alive.
Linda's she took resell the Blanco's
place in Columbia then does down there
running shit cap and motherfuckers
and drive around in a 10 speed.
So what did you turn it into?
I think it was just like some tribal
design or something like that. The Bible,
it was like you don't, you don't
have that much worse. You guys stop.
Sorry. She did some biomech on
that shit. Crazy. All My, all my,
all my work goes down to this.
Some Geiger Shit too.
I want to get tower seven on
my whole would not listen.
We're definitely not saying that.
It just did the portrait of his
new wife on top of that shit
with a chainsaw cutting Linda up like
a chain saw hitting linen and blood
splattered all over.
So it's not Linda's fuck that bitch.
Why didn't he ops to get the
laser on the penis? I don't know.
We know what I don't know. Back
then, I don't think it was as,
I'm like scanning my brain
for any other tattoo.
You reference like laser or
needles. Are you, are you like,
did you have to like pull on it and
like how did you want your butterfly?
Yeah,
no, I mean like if somebody was
sitting, like if he was sitting here,
then I would get dental bibs around all
of it and then I would just, Oh God,
this is awful. No, it's,
no, no, no. There's no,
there's no way is it sexual?
Oh, for sure. No, I'm not saying
that. We're not saying you got off.
Oh my God. The, the middle
of saying, we're just saying,
man, you got it. Is, it is
a very extraordinary task.
You guys take your knuckles and do that.
I had to give him, what did he say?
He just said, did you spit
on it? Oh, come on, man.
That's in the moment. It was, it
was just one of those Daniel Tosh.
Sorry. With the moment. It wasn't forever.
He's ridiculous. Ah, yeah. Look, it's
certainly, it was not sexual. I
mean it has to be insanely painful.
You'd have to be like a really sick,
but then there's a lot of sick fucks who
were like really into pain, right? No,
I think
more embarrassed than anything
and he was really, again,
like his wife was there and it was
a very, you know, I think he was,
I would have made sure it allows
them to have sex right before,
just just in case. Do you think that's
Linda's Goto Shit. The Linda just,
you get a tattoo, my name on your
Dick Damn Way. This kind of work.
She's like, she's a Catholic.
A headboard with like notches.
And how many dudes have
tattooed her name on their deck?
Cic is what a gangster chick.
That chick must be.
Maybe it was his idea to get her back.
Don't doubt it. We need another story.
Numbers. Sorry. You guys
are still friends, right?
No, I mean, no, no. Hold on.
Call that dude up. I'll email them. Know
some things you don't know me,
but I know about your day.
Just curious. Yeah, that's
just don't have the answer.
Have you ever been in the middle
of tattooing someone and Oh,
well for whatever reason they just
told them to get the fuck out of there.
Like I can't do you, you're giving
me bad energy. You're annoying your,
you're crying too much
or have you ever had like
to stop a tattoo?
Um,
probably because of stench a
couple of times now or anything.
No damn bad.
Wiper guys are awful.
Um, no, I dunno. Um, there
was one tattoo that I fuck,
these don't sound like interesting
stories to me, but they probably are. Um,
oh yeah. Um, twice. There's
two different people that um,
like their wife went into labor
during their, their, uh, Tattoo.
One of them was,
it's probably because they knew the
wife knew that you were tattooing the
husband and just awesome.
Like I remember was like mirror survey.
How Tattoo chick. All right. I'm
not smart husband. No, no. I,
this is a great story because it
was, it was very sweet actually. Um,
it was Mira Sorvino is, has been, and she,
he was getting a pinup girl version of
her tattooed on his leg and then halfway
through he got the phone
call and we're like, oh,
we'll just finish it another day. And
sweet. I thought that was nice. Oh,
Dennis Sweet. For sure. Yeah.
Is there a moment that interest,
does anybody ever come to you with some
like crazy demonic shit and you're like,
ah, I just don't want to
get into this? I mean,
I don't do any tattoos that really go
against the navy. Like my moral, I mean,
you know,
the crazy thing is nowadays
it's so different than it
when it used to be like I
used to,
um,
I just tattoo a lot of the people who
are getting tattooed by me now or just
more serious collectors.
So I'm not really dealing with a lot
of riff raff for weirdness of, yeah.
But in the past, I'm digging deep
into the paths right now. So, yeah.
I mean there's sometimes,
uh,
people would come in and wanting to get
tattoos that I don't necessarily agree
with or like I don't,
I don't need the money,
so I don't need to tattoo you if I
don't feel good about it, you know,
if it's something creepy. Yeah.
Though it is my gift to the person.
It's also a collaborative experience,
so I have to feel good about it.
So it also goes for like, things that
I don't think I'm good at. You know,
there's certain things that aren't,
I'm not, I'm just not good at.
I would bet that you would be really
good if you wanted to do like some fall
booth type shit.
I call my old stuffy evil shit.
I like stuff like that. Do that
kind of thing. Yeah. I like,
I just, all kinds of art,
you know what I mean?
I think some of the creepiest stuff is
a lot of like the old Catholic artwork
and it's the reason that it's so
striking and it's so, um, you know, uh,
it, it, it affects and moves people
is because there's like, it's very,
it gives you fear. It's
amazing. It's powerful. So I
love that stuff. Um, you know,
I wear a lot of crosses and stuff and
I may not be for the meanings that most
people assume it would be.
I just like what crosses,
well, a friend of mine went to
Italy and a while he was there,
he took a photo of the sealing of some
religious place that the outside edge of
the photo,
the Center is Heaven,
grace and the outside edge is all
these demons and they're shoving like
pitchforks up dudes asses
crazy back then elite in 10.
The Hieronymus Bosch stuff. I mean,
that's just like, I think faith in the 15,
16 hundreds isn't like the, the uh,
date Danish. I think he was. Um,
I mean that shit was so ahead of its time.
Oh yeah. It's crazy. Scary,
weird. And back then mean
they really believe that too.
I mean, when you were drawing
those paintings of the,
the demons skewering dudes
in their assholes, like,
people really thought that that was going
to happen to you if you died and you
went to hell. Well, I think, uh,
Caravaggios one of my favorite. Yeah.
Uh, you know, from that era, I think he
was one of the first more influential, uh,
painters of the time that started doing
renditions of a biblical stories and
stuff. But painting like Jesus and, um,
painting Jesus more than like a,
a very human like fashion. So it,
it was even more real. Do you know what
I mean? It wasn't like this, you know,
golden era, like aura and raise
and wings and all that stuff.
It's like even made him
look like you and I,
and so you would see like crucifixion
pieces and stuff that, I mean,
you feel it.
It's like
it's fucked up when you look crazy.
All the old crucifixion images
crucifixions are crazy just to begin with
straight up. It's a crazy
way to kill somebody. I mean,
if you just wander around there,
yeah, it's nuts. I mean, but,
but in the old pictures, he was always
like in pretty good shape except for the,
the holes in his arms. I mean, he
wasn't all fucked up. Some body fat,
some selling. I meant what I meant was
he was okay. He wasn't all fucked up,
but like the Mel Gibson movie. Yeah,
but you liked the interpretation of it.
Now it's like if you go to
see that and Mel Gibson movie,
that's our version of what would have
happened when he, but that was horrific.
I mean it was really
scary shit. Like the, the,
the beatings that they did to him and
then they had to have that fake body that
was like bleeding and all these different
areas. I mean it was like a fake robot.
She was like the medieval torture
devices that have been made. I mean,
it's crazy that people even like
invented or thought of things that you,
the racks
and iron maiden's all that horrifying.
No.
Have you ever seen pictures of
the cat piano they used to have?
This is not the only like a hundred
years ago where they had like a bunch of
cats lined up and had these things
that poke the cat and make them me out.
And you played the piano,
the keys. Well, yeah.
They didn't give a fuck about cats back
then. Yeah. The mortality rate for people.
I do too. I love my cat marsh. She
would stop peeing in my fucking house.
How many cats do you have? A
little bitch. I only have one.
I'm not a crazy cat lady. I just
love my cat. When another one
hairless cause I have a hairless cat
and they get kind of the opposite.
He's got full Harry cause your
cat would just kick his cuts.
Asshole is cat's a fluff
ball. Aw, that's cute.
I can't stop my cat from peeing in my
fucking house. She just likes to not Pete.
Where the litter beer boxes he the
most boring interview for you guys like
talking about why? Well I dunno know. I
know we always go there. We always go.
We might be talking about this
seriously. No, no. It's not boring to us.
You're not boring at all.
Don't even say that.
That's not what it is that we talk
about anything and everything.
There's a cat clock. You're the fucking
thing goes off every hour at my house.
Yeah. It ruins story. Arc has 10 minutes.
You're going to hear me and you got to go.
What the fuck?
There's cats all over the desk. Clue who
the guy is obsessed with cats. Oh yeah.
You have something wrong with him.
I don't know what it is.
I just like the lucky count. I don't
know what the fuck's wrong with them,
but he's okay. Do you ever do this fucking
Chad Tattoos? I've done done one. Yeah.
Before a couple of times back
in the day. Yeah. That's cool.
What did you first start
off practicing on Jews?
Pigskin and I just had two people,
but see how is, how was it? No, no,
no.
I was underage so I had a
plethora of friends that were
under agent couldn't get tattooed,
so they were just oh wow. See, tattooed
them or did you get the needles? Um,
well at the time I had a friend that
believed in me and who worked at a shop.
I mean, you know, I was, this was in the
ghetto in San Bernardino, so it's like,
things were a lot different
than they are now.
And so like my first shop that
I worked at, I remember, uh,
it was called Sin City Tattoo at the time.
It was like on Highland and East street,
which is like such a really
gnarly apart out there.
I don't know if it's cleaned up, but I
know there's a jail right down the street.
But um, that's never good. Yeah,
there's like people getting
robbed all the time except us.
Cause I think we were tattooing all
the thieves and stuff, but um, and,
and back then,
like the wars between tattoo shops
are so different and it's all bikers.
You know,
like my,
my boss come to think of it like probably
that probably wasn't even his real
name. I mean, I don't, you know,
like he was gnarly. I mean,
there was wars between Tattoo show.
Yeah.
Like if you opened up a shop in a mile
radius that you would get, I mean, we,
I remember we'd get shot at,
um, what are, what is it called?
Something cocktails with the
fire and Molotov cocktail.
Get those through the window. Really?
Oh yeah. It was crazy. Just, it's just,
it was rough. You guys were working,
this would happen or is it half the time?
I mean, I think my first, yeah, I mean it
was pretty brutal. There's reasons for my,
I feel bad for my parents
because they're like, oh my God.
They had to like imagine all the things,
and I was 16 when I first got into that
shop and I remember going, hey man,
I'm under age. And he's like,
he looks at my shitty portfolio,
Polaroids that were blurry and crappy.
And he was like, Eh, and then, uh,
I shouldn't have my drawings.
And he goes, AH, okay. Yeah,
you could do it. Um, and he,
I remember he used to say, you're going
to fly far, far away. What? I'm like, no,
I'm going to stay here forever. Like,
see you later. San Bernandino. But
wow,
you sold them down the river.
No. You know, it was such a rough, it
was such a rough place to, you know,
it was just a rough place for a
16 year old girl to be at. But um,
San Bernardino's refer your
60. Yeah, totally. It's rough
for everybody. That's a,
that's a tricky area. Yeah. And I lived
right down the street with a prostitute.
At the time and it was rough,
you know, I mean she, it was,
it was awful. He Buddies?
No,
no,
I met her because I had been working at
a movie theater before that passenger
out popcorn and like she worked there
and I needed a place to stay next to the
shop and so,
um,
I would pretty much take care of her
kids while she would go in and out of her
drug. Comatose. So sad. It's
very sad. Wow. Really hard.
But I just knew that if I
could be close to the shop,
I could tattoo everyday in practice and
I would literally go in and open the
shop and stay until minute.
Like, you know, it was like
11 to midnight every day.
I tattooed
so much back then.
How long did it take before
you were comfortable with
the medium of skin of like
moving it around, pulling
it to manipulate it? Yeah,
comfortable from the beginning with
that was because when I was tattooing,
I'm professionally outside of a shop,
not, I didn't know what I was doing,
so there was no bar to, I was like, oh
cool. You want to get a misfit school,
it's awesome. And like I would just
tattoo it and it'd be like, Eh,
it was like eight hours later like,
but um,
then once I got to my first job I had to
unlearn a lot of things and I was like,
what? There's more than one kind of tattoo
machine and different needles and the
cleanliness and the sterility aspect
of it, all the important stuff.
And so I'm just relearning it.
But looking back, you know,
is actually awesome that I was brought
up in that ghetto upbringing because it
definitely is the reason why I tattooed
the style that I do because, um, you know,
gangsters get cool tattoos,
they all get all the fine line
black and gray stuff and they,
I did a lot of names and memory
of his and all that stuff and um,
old English lettering and lots of high
nose and gestures and all this shit.
I wanted to be a comic book
artist when I was a kid. So yeah,
I drew a lot of really
good different wild shit.
One of the things that I did is I drew
on my friends. I would just draw on them.
Like I would draw fake tattoos on them,
like really intense detailed fake
tattoos. It would take like hours. Yeah.
And I did that because I was thinking
about getting a tattoo. Oh yeah. Yeah.
I still draw you all the time to
see it. Yeah. I'll show you this.
I'll send you some shit.
But my best stuff was when I did it
every day and that's when I was in high
school when I was in height.
But I had one conti teacher in high school
as an art teacher, it was so negative.
We want to have anything to do
with art anymore. I was like,
this guy's just a downer. He's
just, it was always negative.
I've failed my art classes in school
but in a lot of visitors cause I was too
punk rock to follow instructions. But
it's like I just, I want to draw it
the way they are. I don't,
I don't, I mean yeah,
let's learn about like the history of
fucking cubism or whatever the fuck you
know.
But like when it comes to drawing stuff,
I don't want to do two point perspective.
I just want to do it as it is
and like I'd rather draw this stapler
like as it is versus like you want to do
what you want to do. Like you can't, you
can't teach in like, you know what I mean?
It's like you can teach
technique, but anyways, I've
failed. I would fail all this,
these, these classes and I'm like,
ah, I don't need this shit. Yeah.
It's like you have an idea
that you want to get out.
You have your expression that you want
to get out and the problem is when
someone says, no, I don't want you to
get that out. I want you to work on that.
It's like you have these brief
moments where these doors are open,
where this creativity wants to run
through and when you're sitting there,
I mean in one sense it's good to be
disciplined and it's good to be regimented
and it's good to have good fundamentals,
but it's also good to just let
it go when you want to let it go.
Like you could learn all those things
on your own time as far as like
perspective and granted, I think there
are some good art teachers out there,
but I think that would be such a tricky
thing to do because it's such a personal
thing too. You know, it's, it would
require a person that was, you know, Doug,
Stan hope and I, we've
talked about teaching comedy
classes that you could never,
first of all,
you can never charge.
Like there's a lot of people that have
like this comedy classes where you're,
you know, you, they charged
this ridiculous amount of money.
You go through all this crazy bullshit
with them and they pretend attorney when
the comedian and we're like, it
should be free. You can't charge.
And you really can't give him any fucking
advice because there's almost nothing
you can tell them.
I mean,
that should be what the comedy club last
one over the last competition was like
came to us right here. Oh really? We're
here all the time. As a matter of fact,
we're here Wednesday night is a Joey Diaz,
Brian Callan,
Duncan Trussell and me. Maybe
Brian if he can come on, sweetie.
Long story deep story. Okay. We
won't go into that, but um, yeah,
it's um, it's awesome place. The Ice
House comedy club has been around forever.
It's been 1961. I think
it's one of the first, uh,
was opened 50 years.
I did my first set here in 94.
Really? Yeah. I want to first moved here
from New York. Comedy's hard, man. I,
there's like, there's a whole, well,
I mean, I just think it's like, it's,
it's not anybody can just go up
there and tell a story. I mean,
some people aren't
really good storytellers,
but I think there's like a whole
thing to it, you know? Well,
you know how [inaudible] for you when
you sit down and you draw, you know,
you're the, you know, it's like, you know,
you know, you know how to fucking draw.
You've been doing it forever.
But if you had never done it before,
a practice it before really
forced your hand to move.
And the way that you want it to
in order to create this image,
it'd be almost alien,
almost impossible for a lot of people.
They look at the artwork that you do
and it's almost incomprehensible to wrap
their head around how much is how someone
could recreate something like that.
How can you do that? How can you
do that? So same thing with comedy.
You do it enough times
or Jujitsu or music,
you do it enough times and it just
becomes, it becomes you. It becomes, yeah.
But yeah, it's hard to get there, but
not really. I mean it is and it isn't.
It's like Joey Dia said it best.
He said comedy is the hardest,
easiest thing you'll ever do because it's
fucking really hard to be good at it.
Yeah.
To get it to where it's easy.
I just can't imagine drawing without
an eraser for a tattoo artist.
That's just seems to me like
the scariest thing in the road.
Cause I've never drawn something that I
didn't erase something on or change or
wish
I did something different. And it is, it
is. There are times when you're tattooing.
I'm like, Shit, I have to
now work around this. Well,
you also got to think about the time
you're putting in as opposed to time she's
putting it. Yeah, I mean she's doing like,
you know, you probably tattooing eight,
10 hours a day, right? How many
hours a day you're doing this?
Oh, nowadays? Or were you when you
started? Oh yeah. I mean it was so,
so many hours. I never, I didn't have
a day off until my first days off.
I started like three or four years
ago I started taking Sundays off. Wow.
Did you ever have any idea that you
could have some sort of reality show type
success? Like Watch TV? I mean,
but was there any idea that you could
have this kind of success? I mean,
did you ever think that, did you
have this in your head that you would
see like things in the like, I see things
differently. Some are, I don't know,
I just see things like, uh, like, oh,
there's an opportunity or oh that you
can make this out of that. You know,
and I think a lot of people, maybe
you're just blind themselves to that.
So I don't know. I never wanted
that. It's not, I actually was,
but it didn't exist before.
Well, it didn't exist. Celebrity
tattooist didn't exist.
I mean the ED hardy type dudes.
There was a few names. Yeah.
The polls. I never in a
million years imagined. Yeah.
The staff. I mean if you knew
like where I was born in,
how would you know where I come from?
It's like totally different than it's
the opposite of this stuff, you know?
But I don't know. It's not, I dunno,
I'm not that impressed by that stuff.
It's cool. It's cool and I'm very
appreciative. It's like awesome. Like, Oh,
I get to do more of this
stuff, you know? But
well, when I talk about it and I'm not
saying it in terms of like your, your,
your common perception of how people view
success and look at her, she's on TV.
Yeah.
It's not that.
What I mean is how receptive people
are and how much resonance your work is
having on people.
Never in a million years.
Yeah. I mean, I was like, you know, like
that's like the weird girl here, whatever,
you know, like the fact that, oh,
maybe that's why I'm bad
at compliments and stuff.
So he knows and it's like I'm
just not used to that still. Yeah,
that's gotta be kind of
awkward. Right. But it's a,
it's a really fascinating but not done.
But now that I'm not like how he
thinks I used to be, I guess it's like,
yeah. Oh, that's when you were
hotter back then. Oh, see dude,
I told you she's still riding on that.
We let that Joe,
we let that joke fly over our hands,
but she's still holding on to way like
a hot lava rock and her arms burning or
soul. Oh, no way. No Way. By the way, look
how beautiful her shoes look today. Joe W,
why do you like shoes or something?
Because I'm just kidding.
I sort of came from Disneyland, so
I'm like, cool. There's such a stigma.
Even I'm guilty of that too.
I like shoes or something.
No. Oh No. Oh, I'm not a fan.
I love shoes. I'm a normal guy.
Usually. Usually. Look growing up,
you think tattoos? Like
for me, tattoos. Look,
my uncles had tattoos that, you
know, I'm sure that influenced me.
But you know, generally girls that got
tattoos, they generally weren't hot.
Right? Generally. Yeah.
And I can imagine the,
the,
the amount of guys who
thought like, damn, she's
so hot, she's ruining herself with
the tattoos or something. And,
and now look at her now.
You know what I mean?
Most guys wouldn't think that though.
An illusion that girls have. I think,
you know,
most guys you'd be amazed at how little
we give a fuck about like a lot of shit
that you have more different generation.
That's all you guys
were in the body shape.
You change the perception single handedly
though. Oh yeah. Without a doubt.
You'd definitely threw a monkey wrench
into the whole idea of what's hot.
And there was,
there was one movie which he took a deep,
there was a movie with Will Ferrell, I
think it wasn't like a, an extreme comedy,
but the love interest and they never
really addressed it in the movie had a
sleeve,
you know what I'm talking about right?
The love interest had a sleeve and
I think it was fake or whatever,
but they never talked about it.
She was just a chick who worked at a
bakery and will Ferrell. I think that's,
it was like fell in love with her
or whatever and that never existed.
Yeah.
And all the movie offers,
I haven't ever gotten her like a
hooker drug dealer of an player.
What else? Zombie random goth chick.
Uh, other, yeah. It's never club scene.
The Queue. It's will Ferrell
or whatever. That's funny.
Yeah.
It's weird how the perception of what
tattoos are over the last couple of
decades. But like when I was
a kid, no one had sleeves. My,
my friend's Dad's never had sleeves,
you know, that's weird. But then,
you know, uh, today it's so
common. It's, I mean, what are the,
how much more common is our tattoos
today then when we were kids,
she is huge and you got to
talk into the thing, man.
Victor are really good friends.
A friend of ours has a son,
his name is Tori and Victor has sleeps.
He has a lot of tattoos and
his son is 11 or 12 now.
And the last time I hung out with him
his son was drawing on himself for the
whole night.
He had like just marked,
it felt like really cool
cause he was like his dad.
So that would be a key for sure.
He's going to get tapped days that
it just seems like he is. Yeah.
Kids are always more open minded and
stuff cause they're not like painted by
like he would get the tattoos because
he thought it was cool cause his dad,
cause him and his dad have an amazing
relationship. There's, there's,
there's no lack of love in that kid's
life. Yeah. So you know, I'm just kidding.
Oh no shit. She just hit you with
the real son. It is true though. His,
his dad's awesome. Oh
yeah, Victor's got, yeah.
Yeah that kid. Probably mom. It's a weird
rite of passage thing too for young man.
It's like when some young kids want
to smoke and there's, you know,
they're not around their parents.
They want to have that cigarette
so he can pretend to be an adult.
They have friends that smoke, like
older friends or something. Yeah.
That or if they see their parents do
it and they sneak them out and they get
them together, you know, that's what I did
when I was a kid. We'd sneak out booze,
saw our parents drinking
so it's fine booze,
my parents' house and sneaking out into
the woods and we would do it cause we
pretend to be like adults,
you know,
installing really like we wanted to get
drunk. We're only gonna like 11 you know,
the like, you know, kids do
that. They, they, they, the
hell is wrong with me, man.
My parents were so square and like,
it sounds like your parents are just super
disciplined. Where did I get it from?
Miami.
It's just a reaction
to that. The fact that you had to
practice all the time and you were very,
very regimented and disciplined and,
and you just became a,
a wild sort of thing because of that,
because of the fact that you were right.
So a boxed in by a rigid sort of,
but it wasn't wild. I mean, no, I looked
crazy, but I was, I just loved punk rock.
It's probably just music then
Flint and music. I think it was,
it was like there's something,
there's more out there. Yeah.
If you're totally into punk,
you're going to get some tattoos.
Eventually you're going to get
something, something. Yeah.
If you're really into punk,
that black flag thing you might
get that's barely got those bars.
Like last month I was like,
can't believe I haven't black flag bars.
They'll really just got
them all. That's cool. Yeah.
That's, you're like, oh my God,
I forgot that one shit. No, it's
like, how did I not have that already?
Do you, uh, I mean you said he covered
up some that were under your left arm.
Are you done covering own
or do you look at your own
look? A few that like, oh,
I have one on my leg that I
started lasering would hurt
so much analysis. I just,
again, time consumption. It's harder
for me to get tattooed cause I'm busy.
They're doing them or doing all the
other stuff I do. So it's like, but yeah,
there's a few. I think I would, I mean,
just for the sake of making more
room or something like, yeah,
like isn't that crazy though? Maybe just
spend, doctors will become popular again.
Do you have any
bands are just like totally
whacked at a tattooed on, you know,
I only listen to rap music,
but I mean at one point in time
you loved them and now you're like,
I can't blame a tattooed those guys on me.
I think I've always liked rap music.
Always been cool.
You've always had good taste.
So with the ones that you were,
you're thinking about laser and off,
you just have some ideas that
you need some space for it.
No, I mean, and there's just some
that like, I, I don't have regrets.
I can live with him or without him, you
know? But I think like, I, it's not,
I don't know, like I haven't had that many
boyfriends in my entire life, you know,
cause I'm always the
cue that Violin Violet,
I'm just saying that know you got to
be quicker with that, Brian. Yeah.
You gotta be ready with
those on that's terrible. No,
but like I've gotten tattoos for
maybe the whole community walk away.
Oh, that's what it was.
Well that's a terrible,
you know the end of the, yeah.
Sorry, I'm just hearing you guys,
I'm sorry this is so you don't have,
you haven't had that many boyfriends
and I mean I think I've gotten like some
tattoos for um,
whatever those relationships in Pasadena.
Like my first tattoo was a j and
whatever and I still love it,
but I think there's like two portraits
I'd like to get lasered off you.
It seems like for you, I
mean, correct me if I'm wrong,
but it seems like
at least if I had to guess,
it's probably very difficult for you to
enter into a relationship because you
seem to be like one of
those all in sort of girls.
Like you fall in love with someone
and yeah. All or nothing. Yeah. Yeah.
So you're ready right away, all an all
or nothing and then it doesn't work.
It's nothing. And then just like, it's
hard to make that. It's hard to pull that
trigger. We, what do you mean?
What score would you pull that all
or nothing trigger? I don't know.
Any other way. That's what I'm saying.
I mean it seems that that's your style.
Your, yeah. Is that bad? No, no
it's, but it's hard. It's not bad.
Which cause you look,
if you find her to make a connection
with people that are like true or true to
themselves and see like most of
the time people when you meet them,
they're putting,
uh,
like putting out like a perception of
themselves is how they would like to be
seen.
So you're already going through like two
layers right there of what the person
really is. Or sometimes it might even be
bullshitting themselves. Yeah. So like,
whereas I'm not by any means perfect,
but I pretty much like I talk a lot,
I've talked about the
same stuff. Like, oh,
this is the same conversation I'd
have with like my homie. It's like,
you know what I mean? Like it's kind of
what you see is what you get, you know?
And I've only met very few
people that are that way. And,
and so I think that oftentimes you've
tend to fall in love with this perception
versus the person. And so in my case,
sometimes I feel like it's all, it's,
it tends to be intense in the beginnings.
And then I'm good tenure being on fire
and then maybe it's not so much that way,
but I'm also a very emotional person.
I'm gonna be like very, you know,
till the bitter end.
Well,
sometimes people can bullshit you for
quite a long time before you really get
used to what they're really
like. Yeah, yeah. Totally.
Three or four months in you like three,
four minutes is so short of a time of
day. It is a short amount of time. Yeah,
it is.
But you could find out everything about
someone and three or four months of
constantly being with them, they can
only hide their character for so long,
which is I think, but I always wonder
about like, dudes like Paul Mccartney,
Paul Mccartney is a bad motherfucker.
But then you'd hear that ex
wife talk about m. And. T.
You ever heard of the one the woman
who had lost her leg in a motorcycle
accident? No. Cheese demonic. I mean,
the way that lady would talk about Paul
Mccartney was like the most terrifying
thing. Like it was just, she's ridiculous.
I don't want to hear about that stuff.
Yeah, you don't want to hear it. You
super negative. I want to hear, well,
super negative about if
anything ever happened to her.
She has information hidden
secret places about him.
I'm doing the best to protect my husband.
She was like just a crazy evil person and
wanted stacks of cash from him and his
dumb ass didn't get a prenuptial and he
got roped in by a woman pretending to be
something she wasn't.
And then once he had a kid with her,
she just turned on the hooks and fucking
ripped her chest open and a monster
flew out. And that was her. And
that was all the interviews.
After that you would listen
to the interviews and you go,
how did he not see this common man?
How do they not know that he
was with a crazy person of this
does you want to believe
in? I think people's ability
to be something, you know?
Yeah, for sure. Also, he came
out of a longterm relationship
with Linda Mccartney,
who was supposed to be an amazing person,
like really nice sweet woman.
By all accounts they got along great.
So he's probably his ideas of
what relationships were like.
He really thought that's what you
did. You know, you find someone,
you just nice to them,
they're nice to you.
And this is just the way she really is.
He didn't even look for
all the clues of credit
maybe. I mean, who knows? You know
what I mean? I always think it's like,
unless you're in it, you're really
don't know what's going on, you know?
Right. That's why you speculate it's
fun and he talk shit at the same time.
It's great.
It's good times speculating and talking
Shit and how Paul Mccartney got roped in.
Yeah, I dunno. So you haven't had that
many boyfriends because of that because,
no, no, no, no. I know.
I think I haven't had that many boys
cause I'm always in longterm relationships
I think is what it is. He's like,
so you haven't had any boyfriends.
Damn man. You make me feel creepy.
What did he come up with that?
Thank you Brian. Thanks for
[inaudible] but no, no. Anyway, so
go get it.
Come on or tattoo again.
It's really important story
ever been to the off guard
most ridiculous shit ever. Yeah, I
don't know. Yeah, love is a funny thing.
It's hard as fuck, but you got to find
the right person. That's what it is.
I mean the right person for you might
not be the right person for somebody else
and finding that perfect
interaction with people.
It's almost impossible. It's so
hard. It's so hard to line up,
especially for a chick like you know,
because you have to have some like
some serious bad motherfucker.
You can't just have like some
regular tude pretty good.
The heart related to be honest,
when it comes to like the amount of like
solidness that I, that I guess every,
yeah, but for a dude to not be tweaked
by you being all hot and famous,
covered in tattoos and all wild,
crazy famous tattoo lasers.
That's a serious obstacle.
Like a Braveheart dude,
some Mallory warrior,
he's like,
it's just seems like I would just
want to be with somebody who,
who can get it, you know, and like I
could relate to or understand, you know,
Chubby as a comic or something.
He's putting himself out there.
That's what he's doing. My creepiness.
I like intelligence.
Jennifer Lopez,
she's doomed to a life of Betas.
She's going to have to date these Beta
men and buy them cars and there'll be
younger than her and that's it.
That's just the way it goes from now on.
This is no, it should be a batter
motherfucker than Jennifer Lopez.
Good luck. Good luck feller. Who the fuck
is, it was like, this is what you got.
Like Brad Pitt and a couple other dudes.
The only people who can data.
Her dating pool is down to
like five people and most
of them are married already.
It's like good luck, but she'll,
she's got to go the other way.
I think you're going to have
to have gone that way too.
You're going to have to get some
Beta, his man, servant type dudes.
I'm telling you. That's what I want
to bring Brian into. Your Life.
Shit will be perfect. Would
worship you. He would set up,
set up your website.
It said
he could really spice up your
Twitter background. Right.
Can Make Shit happen.
Yeah, I, I dunno. That's funny.
Shit. Hey, it's, it's the
fucking, that's the big mean.
If there was one dilemma that people
find in life that's most prevalent in our
society,
it's finding the right person.
It's like probably the biggest dilemma
that anybody ever faces when you're
growing up.
Especially me. You're always like, man,
if I could just find the right girl
if I give is find the right guy for
everybody.
That's like the number one.
It's hard. It's like working on
yourself first and then they,
then you put yourself in a position,
you know what I mean?
Because I know that like in
the past where, you know,
it's kind of like the hippie stuff we
talked about earlier. It's like, you know,
water seeking its own level.
And um, I feel like, like I
look back at like my last,
you know, the relationship
that was an an an awful mass.
It's like a part of me feels like,
oh my God, I got duped or something.
But then another part of me is like,
I created this to a certain degree too.
If it's like, if, if there's like,
there's red flags that I failed to see
because I wanted to believe that it was
something else. I know people do that
all the time, so it's more like, okay,
well w at the end of the day, like, what's
wrong with me? You know what I mean?
Like what, what was my part in it? What
could I have done to not, you know,
obviously that does not discredit
people's like shitty behavior. You know,
obviously some people suck and stuff.
And some people are really good liars
and whatever, but like I think, uh,
do you have to grow as well?
Yeah,
I think it's,
I think it's more important to put
yourself in a situation where you can be
receptive to a healthy
relationship. Like, you know,
when I was depressed I like kind of
gravitated towards other people that were
also sad and, and that doesn't
help. You know what I mean?
So I think as far as like what you're
saying is like finding somebody at a level
or whatever. Yeah, there's that Nice
understandability like, you know,
I can talk about things that bug me that
may not bug like a regular person or
whatever, but it's more like the
connection of the mind, you know?
I want to be inspired by somebody who
is equally as driven and equally like
wanting to create and like
that shit drives me crazy.
Like when someone's into it, you know,
whether you're a busboy or fucking famous.
Yeah. What I'm saying is you're fucked.
You're never going to find a dude. Like,
I read poetry and then why
do you think it's better?
That crazy thing is I said
the c word earlier, Jesus,
anybody dating like a Jessica Alba,
that dude has to deal with the fact that
she's really good friends with a lot of
a list celebrities. Right. So
that's what you want to throw a gun.
This is the Siberia thing cause it's
like all those things are mentally
generated ideas of what's important
or what's good. Like, like,
like I don't see it that way.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm not saying I could
fall in love with, with anybody,
but like if it fits your mind or your
soul, whatever you want to call it,
like I could fall in love with that. It
really does not have to do with um, what,
what the world's perception of you is.
Yeah.
You say that,
but you got to find out how much
the gardener makes and was like,
bitch can't even take me out to do
than shit we got going on here.
It's not that way.
It like is she with dudes paying
for my stuff? Do you really? Yeah,
I think it's probably because I was my
own set of issues is like, you know,
I'm not a feminist or like I don't
consider myself anything but like I think,
you know, just growing up poor, I'm
always like, oh, I can do it myself.
Don't write a door for me. Like,
yeah, no, that makes sense.
I would hate to be a girl and have dudes
buy me dinner and then expect something
from,
no,
it's a sincere gift. Is it a
difference? You know? But I
also like, um, I don't know.
Yeah,
you got to be single for a long time.
Kid stuck in a workout downer.
Damn,
you're too much of a bad motherfucker.
It's really going to be hard.
Rock star friends, she's like really good.
Close to, yeah, you get those guys alone.
They all fall apart.
But
that would intimidate some
guys. Guys would be like, damn,
she's best friends with him. Him hitting
her, you know? That would be the most,
one of the saddest things,
if you look really into a rock star and
then you started dating him when he was
just a whiny bitch, you'd be like,
really, man, you stopped liking the music.
Your fucking music was awesome.
Imagine if you started dating Mick
Jagger just found out he's a cunt.
Just Mick Jagger's off fucking
dumb con. You're like, what?
God dammit. That has to be the hardest
for a girl. Did a rockstar fighter.
He's a Dork. That would be the hardest
shit ever. But the Rock Mick Jagger,
that would crush the rock star.
Fuck yeah. Yeah. Wow. Yeah,
that'd be devastating. Rockstars don't
get broken up with. They do though.
They get dumped, especially
in this day and age. You know,
I think in the protected days of the
60s and the 70s like I've read some shit
about Hendrix,
man.
I got so bummed out because I'm a huge
Hendrix fan and I was reading an expert,
expert excerpt from this,
a book about him,
and one of them was like about Jimmy
Hendrix beating the shit out of his
girlfriend. They're like, Jimi Hendrix
would just smack around. We weren't there.
That's the thing. It's true. You're right.
Standing up for women beaters. I like it.
[inaudible]
Jamie kills teen.
No, no, you're absolutely right.
You're the guy was a band member.
He could have been a jealous bitch.
He's the guys in the band with one
of the greatest [inaudible] beating.
It just cleans. That's what he
likes. Lassen is coffee. No,
but I mean who knows what really happened.
But reading about that, it was like,
wow,
that's so like you read like some tweets
that like Chris Brown makes and these
fucking moron.
He makes these tweets and everybody
hates them and to go after him.
Then he deletes these tweets. What does
he say? Just really stupid shit about,
oh he's, you know, after
the whole Rihanna thing,
he would like get in arguments with
people about him beating up women and they
were, they were like,
really? He's a moron.
So there were like really gross
kind of tweets. But this, this,
that didn't exist. Like in
the, the led Zeppelin days,
there was no Twitter.
If they had a podcast or
a Internet radio show,
we got to hear them argue about
chicks on the road who you know,
and you'd be like, Oh, you guys are gross.
It's like the mystery was so much better
than, you know, it's like Robert Plant,
the mystery of Robert Plant. I remember
growing up being a huge Zeppelin fan.
I mean I barely knew 10
words at plant said in
an interview, you know, I think I
heard any interviews. I just knew,
I just knew black dog was the shit,
you know.
I just knew whole lot of love is like
the greatest song in the history of the
world.
That's all I knew.
I didn't know anything about Robert Plant
and it might be annoying as fuck and
you,
you've dated Robert Plant.
It just turns out to be a total prima
Donna knowing and stupid and always
insecure and once everybody
kisses ass like fuck. Really?
It's like when Mel Gibson was screaming
at that ex-girlfriend shot up,
blow me and he's like yelling at her,
answering so much.
I'm sure she was. I'm sure
she was. But it was like,
we never got a chance to see someone so
human before that was like a fucking Mel
Gibson mean.
He was brave heart and then all of a
sudden he's screaming to some scammer,
some Russian scammer chick who's robbing
him and recording all of his phone
calls.
Shut up and blow me. And I'm like, wow.
Like this is Mel Gibson man.
This is the lethal weapon dude.
What the fuck? Kind of just like
that character and lethal weapon.
Wasn't he like a crazy,
he would.
Yeah, but he was kind. He was crazy. But
kind to women with the CRA the wrong.
What was wrong with the crazy?
What was wrong with the crazy first of
all does he was scary as fuck to a woman
who had his child.
Like he couldn't even keep it together
to this woman who had his child.
That was the scariest thing.
It's like he had a baby with this person.
She's watching his baby and he's fucking
screaming bloody murder at her. That's,
he's a scary dude,
you know. Did that freak you
out? The Mel Gibson Shit?
I am known to give it a bad talk about
Mel Gibson. No, no. I just, it's like,
I don't know. You didn't hear that.
That thing when it was in the news.
I really don't watch television.
I like knowing the human side of people.
I love reality shows.
I actually do mob wives
and moms and Mama drama.
Forget about a watch monitor wives,
the one with the little girl,
the Mama drama,
they take,
they take six sets of mothers and
daughters like that party together.
They were like 43 and 22
and they put six couples athlon black,
half them white in a penthouse in
Vegas and they get drunk everyday.
It's hysterical. Wow.
It's great. That's genius.
Yeah. There's some fun in reality
shows, but you know it's, it's,
it's really like mindless
distraction. That's the
problem. You don't get anything.
Sometimes you need that.
Sometimes you need to do you like that?
I like not thinking about shit and
watching South Park or watching some mine.
I W I want to be mindless. It's like
meditation. I don't mind mindlessness of,
it's in the form of comedy,
like Southpark type.
It's nice knowing how people really are
like, Holy Shit, mob lives. Chicago.
People aren't really like
that. They're not. No.
I mean I think you're putting
a hyper it, it's such a, yeah,
that's the alcohol they put, make them
live together. It's edited and produced.
I totally believe
that. Not really how, whatever.
But really our people that are acting
like that on camera and that's as fast as
that. Yeah, I love it. I definitely
doesn't inspire me though. That shit.
Some days mob lives comes out.
Are you kidding? So stupid. The,
the real housewives of Beverly Hills.
I watched the real housewives
of Miami ad the other day,
just the ad and I cringe and I
just grabbed the remote controller,
shut it off quick.
Like just thinking that these women could
enter into my life somehow or another
through me watching them on TV,
but somehow or another they can make
their way into my life would be annoying
and yapping at me and they were hitting
each other and screaming at each other,
you know, he and Miami, you got to do this
and you're going to do that. Then. Oh,
come on. I don't watch that show.
Just, I don't watch all reality shows.
Just a couple. We got, there's
gotta be fighting and violence.
If there's not fighting,
I don't want to watch it.
Is that a weird position for you to be in
a reality show when you, you know, you,
you're,
you've got a very different sort of a
reality show because it's obviously a
reality show about your artwork. I
mean, it's about your expression.
It's about originally
docu series. It was a very formatted
show is like where you, you,
the premise was like you would
learn the story about the tat,
the story behind each of the tattoos
and the interaction between tattooer and
client.
And then that,
and then like I was 80% of the show in
the 20% of it was our own personal life
stories. You know, that we're
somehow connected to tattooing.
And then as the show went
on, I can't, man, I can't
believe we were on for so long,
you know? And um, how many seasons
where you on for? It's, it's,
it's weird because, uh, contractually
it's different. It's different.
We were basically on for, uh,
seven years. Six or seven years.
Wow.
That's incredible. Yeah. What's
a great premise for a show? Yeah.
Two more.
The it flipped,
so it's like 20% are an 80% drama and
most of it was produced. Hence, oh,
that girl got on the show,
which I don't know.
Yeah. Well why do that? See
that's, that's Hollywood idiots.
Because I think first of all,
I'm a fan of tattoos and ours of course,
and just having a show where it was just,
you produce it,
you dictate what's going on.
Just about the actors.
It seems like you could do that though.
Yeah.
And people would enjoy it
and it would be pure. I mean,
I would watch a time lapse of, oh my God,
that's the old footage. Why shouldn't it?
Why should you do it that way?
I mean,
it seems like someone who would be an
idiot to try to do it in any way other
than your personality.
Why would they not do that?
Really? It's the way it's not,
it's not the, it's the demand.
Do you know what I mean? It's, it's
not the domain. It is the demand.
Because what it is,
it's like it's,
it's all based on money and
numbers for the network.
So whatever situations and drama show
peaks and they have these tests that they
run, that's what they,
and I don't believe it.
I can't disagree more with
you. Hey listen, this is why
I would, I, I'm on your, I'm on your
side. I know you are. I know you are.
But the way that the network sees it is
what's going to generate more money and
it's going to be viewership.
Cause they could sell advertisement
that's wrong about that.
I know they are of the wrong.
That's why they've
killed.
I mean it played it out.
Well what they're doing is
they just go with the box.
They go with what's word with
what's worked before. This
is the formula, you know.
Okay, here's the wacky neighbor. Go.
You know, I mean that's the formula.
I mean they don't, it doesn't have to be
that. That's so silly. Wacky neighbor. He,
you're whacking Eva. Brian, you
want to be ever wacky neighbor.
He would be awesome at it.
Give you the work you've done.
He's a breakthrough talent.
I'm telling you,
you can really knock you
guys over the top, bring it,
bring the ratings to the top.
It's just people enjoy people
who are really good at things.
I mean that's really what it is.
That people also enjoy train wrecks,
which is why you love the house wide,
but you don't only enjoy it.
They only do.
But I think that there is
definitely people and some people,
not everybody, but some people
get lost in, um, in, in that
they do. But it's not like, look,
there's a lot of dumb shit on my DVR.
There's plenty of dumb
shit. I'm, I mean I do,
I watch dumb shit both for escape and
for material because there's some funny
shit in it.
Yeah.
But it's also like a lot of like really
intelligent shit on my DVR to like
documentaries that Morgan Freeman show
through the wormhole fucking amazing show.
But it's like the same people watch both
things and I think that a well produced
version of your show that's,
you decide what the fuck goes on.
You decide you're the
artists. Yeah. Of course you,
you talk to these people about their,
their ideas,
you create their tattoos and stop fucking
around with all that fake shit and it
would be beautiful. That
dumb mother fuckers I Kat Von
d alone. You stupid fucks.
No,
I just think Hollywood hacks.
You just got to cut out that
middle man and cookie cutter cuts.
You don't know what you're doing.
Leave her alone.
Yeah. Yeah. That's it. You
tell them. Yeah. Those fucks
creating some fake nonsense.
Silly, silly bitches. Yeah.
I ended up just filming,
like I secretly filmed the documentary.
Oh. Uh, for the last three years now.
We actually finally pretty much done
with it. And, um, and it's, it's awesome.
It's so freeing,
you know,
to be able to do it that way and
having the control and stuff.
I wish I could have given as, as much
as I gave him my documentary to show,
but I really couldn't because it
wasn't mine, you know? And um,
you should totally have your
own show for the Internet.
It'd be fucking gigantic. Just,
just film while you're working,
you're going to do it anyway. Just film
while you're working, loosely edited,
you know,
throw a little bumper in the beginning,
throw that shit online and get a million
views a day. Yeah. What he wants to see.
Good stuff.
I know, but I want to create things
with a lot of qualities. I'm not,
I can't just like have fast edit stuff,
you know, just slap that bitch together.
I have to get like my friend who does,
you know,
Clyde butcher and did like to kind
of a control freak too. No, no, no.
I just have an excellent, I just having
creative intention. Right. Right. So,
uh, whatever, but I mean an
excellence freak. You want
it to be x. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um, but yeah, I think now nowadays,
just with everything I
have going on and it just,
it's so time consuming to do television.
Do you take on apprentices or do you
have assistants or people who ever work
with you want to learn how to Tattoo?
Was that ever happened?
Don't, at our shop, you know, I have
20 guys that worked with me and I love,
we're like, we're brothers and sisters
with 20 guys. I mean, you know,
this is includes like our shop managers
and stuff like that, you know, and,
and like Dennis, he's like my first
guy ever hired. He's like still there.
Everybody's and we're so close, like
what you see on television. Those were,
you know,
like the,
the cast members that they didn't work
at the shop with the exception of Dan
Smith.
Like everybody else kind of just kind of,
they weren't really the true Hvt crew,
you know what I mean? Right. But, um,
and we love each other.
We love the way it is.
And I feel like when you have
an apprentice that changes
the dynamic because it
makes somebody better than somebody else.
And the way that we work is that we're
all good at what we do in different ways.
So we're all better and not as good as
each other and we inspire each other and
keep each other, you know what
I mean? So it's a collective,
it's like totally collective
and it's awesome. That sounds
bad ass. It is. I mean,
it's, how does someone break
into your fold? How someone,
that's the hardest thing is
like, we've, like, we've never,
every time we've let anybody outside the
circle and it's never really worked out
the way we need it. So it's
always a, you know, it's,
it's basically just who we know
and kind of comes through that way.
Were there any people that you work
growing when you were growing up that
you look towards for inspiration that,
that inspire you and, and,
and, and like just give you,
gave you momentum to create or,
um, yeah, I mean, I think
like when I was a kid,
I used to look at Tattoo magazines and
when I say kid, I mean like 16 and stuff.
And like I remember looking up to
Jack Rudy, he was like, oh yeah,
the black and gray God father and all this
stuff and amazing work. That guy. Yeah.
Yeah. And so, uh,
the day I turned 18 I had beforehand
I made an appointment with him.
And really it's an advanced.
And I was so excited about it and
I went and got this tattoo and um,
and I sat there for the fucking
six hours it took or whatever.
And it's one of my favorite tattoos.
It's so beautiful. I still love it. Um,
but I remember him sitting
there going like, ah, you know,
you guys don't have any
business in the business.
And all of a sudden I was like an 18
year old kid back then and you know,
he's very old school and like
sees things a different way.
And at the time I was like, heartbroken,
you know, it was like, oh, uh,
my, uh, here, I don't
know he's been a hero,
but like he was somebody I admired
his work just like shut me down.
But then at the same time like, ah,
it's cool. Like, I'll watch this. Like,
you know what I mean? And
then, and now, you know, fast
forward now that mean we've,
we know each other and you know, he's,
did you tell him that story? Um, no.
He knows it. He doesn't remember.
Yeah, he, I bet he doesn't remember.
You have, I mean, I remember like,
uh, one of the coolest stories. Yeah.
When I was tattooing unprofessionally,
when it was like an amateur,
like 16 year old I went into,
I had heard that there was this girl
who owned a shop in Culver city.
It was like the only female artists,
that own shop. I was like, whoa.
And her name was Erica Stanley.
She was bad ass.
And so I remember going down national and,
and I go in there and I was
like, oh my God, we're here.
And it was just a tattoo shop,
whatever. And I see her and she's like,
really beautiful. And like,
she's just like a power,
like she's like a force of
nature. And, um, she's like,
can I help you? And I'm like,
yeah, you know, and I was just
probably being over over the cocky,
you're thinking that I had gained a place
in the tattoo industry when I was just
a 16 year old little punk in with a,
with a bullshit bang on my arm.
And it's like, and, and I'm just like,
oh man. So do you have any advice for me?
And I remember, she's like, yeah, Ma,
the best advice I could give
you as a run while you can.
And I remember I was so pissed off
like, oh yeah, well fuck you. You know,
and I left and then years later I
understood what she meant by it. You know,
it wasn't that she was saying, Oh, you're
not good enough. It's just like, ah,
like if you got the eye of the tire,
you're going to do it and
you're figure out your yourself.
There's nothing I could tell you.
It's to make you better as you know,
if I were to sit there and cuddle
you, like good as that. And she, she,
she saw tattooing a sacred,
and I remember I went to,
my first tattoo convention was
18. I was like, ink slinger is,
I don't even know if it's still,
it's still around, but um,
and one of these guys that I
tattooed a Vargas portrait on,
entered it into the context of best black
and gray. And she was the judge. And, uh,
you know,
she never knew my name at the time when
I was 16 and I got first place and she
voted for me. And I remember going
up to check, oh, congratulations.
It was really beautiful. I'm like, Hey,
you know what's funny? When I was 16,
I went to your shop and you told me
that I should go run while I can.
And she goes, oh my God. No. I'm like,
I just want to say thank you. It's cool,
you know? And well, you accepted that
inspiration. The right word. Yeah. Yeah.
She's still bad ass. It was, it was,
it was cool. You know, she's still,
I think a pioneer as far as la goes,
you know,
and it's cool comics
and,
um,
tattoo artists have a lot in
common in that it's a very much a,
an outside chance of success. We're all
fucked up. Yeah. We're all both of, yeah,
we're,
we're both fucked up.
We both have too much
expression and it's a,
it's one of those things where
like, you know, if you say,
what does your daughter do?
Oh, my daughter's a tattoo
artists. Like, oh Jesus,
your picture and fucking bikers
bars. And I'd be scared if you told
me her daughter's a cheerleader.
Oh yeah. Around football players. Yeah.
Ridiculous. But you know, you say,
oh my daughter's Kat von d. It's
like, oh, she's a famous celebrity.
Tattooist I've seen that show.
She's beautiful.
Different sort of, you know,
it's like as you, you tell you,
if you try to tell your
parents you want to be a comic,
they look at you like good fucking luck.
Like you need to get a
job that's going to work.
Like that's not what do you really want
to do? Yeah, exactly. Well, you know,
you need to have a backup plan and you
know, I don't think anybody before you,
that's the, the nuttiest thing about
what you did is you became like mean Ami.
I guess his famous too, but he's not
famous in the same way. You know,
that show was that the first show Miami
ink was at the first of those ink shows.
He, for whatever reason, it's just,
it never, it wasn't the same thing.
Is that what it is? Yeah,
I think so. I mean people,
I mean a guy with the shirt off.
And I'm not saying that he's not a,
I don't know him anymore. I haven't
seen him in years since those times.
And back then I was a drunken
mess. But um, you know, people can,
I think your looks get you so far,
you know,
and after a while you have to actually
care about what you're doing and,
and you know what I mean? So I think
at the time it was probably hard.
I can only assume how difficult it
would be for something new. Like
there's a sensation of a new
tattoo show and being like the,
the front man for that must be
a sidetracking at times. Maybe.
I'm not sure in the,
you can make mistakes,
but if you could go back and do it again,
knowing the reaction to
all those different things,
how we do something a little
different. Yeah, yeah.
I know what you're talking about.
So it's that, that, you know,
sometimes it's hard when there's
no one fucked up before you,
no one fucked up before you that you could
watch and learn from all the fuck ups
and you get all the assholes in the world.
And it'd be like,
I don't want to be like them. There
you go. They end, they, you know,
and that is the case. I mean, you
know, we, we don't live in a vacuum.
We all need those assholes to show us.
What's what it feels like to watch someone
be an asshole. I know. I think it just,
as much as you need inspirational people,
I guess we need them all.
We need everybody, right? Prime. Oh
yeah. What are you doing over there?
Drinking coke. Sarah caught you off guard.
Chugging. Well listen, Kathy has been
a lot of really, really interesting.
Anytime, anytime you know you, you're
very easy to talk to. A really,
really cool to talk to him.
Fun have on your life.
Do you have like three
years or something crazy?
Like would you be willing to draw a
death squad cat on Brian's back draw or
Tattoo Tattoo? I'm sorry. You know what
I mean? I mean he did get mine fixed.
Oh yeah, the one that's fucked
up. Yeah. We'll pull that shit up.
What could you do to that?
What could you do that?
Would he have to go and get that
lasered? The options are endless. Nah,
you can do something. You got options.
Really? We'll talk. Cool. Really?
You think you could do a cover up on that?
That's beautiful. Look at that Brian.
We've got something going on here
for you. It's beautiful. Listen,
is there anything that people,
anything you're sewing.
I know you had a book out
for awhile. People buy that.
I'm not a good commercial.
Do you have a website that people can
go and stalk you from her book is,
I actually figured out her
books online here. Here it is.
You guys are forcing stuff on it.
We're happy to have you.
I'm honored that you chose to
come here and hang out with.
I wanted to come and seen her. Oh No. It's
awesome. Anytime you want to come back,
please come back. It was really
fun. It's very fun talking to you.
Check her out on Twitter, the Kat von d
you dirty Fox and a and also Eddie Bravo,
Chuck Eddie, Bravo out and
10th planet J J. Dot Com.
Go and learn how to choke people,
Bitch, and had to get it together.
Put it together on the map. Good desk
squad. Got TV pickups from cat shirts.
Brian's got to available.
There's still some of the original
available and the new ones. Oh,
they're not yet. No, I got to get
them out of the warehouse. Okay,
we'll get him out of the warehouse. Um,
and uh, thank you to [inaudible] dot com.
That's o n n I t. Use the code name.
Got Your back. What's Today's date?
The 10th, the 10th. For two
more days you get 18% off. Um,
and after that code name Rogan,
you will save 10% off any and all orders
of supplements. All right, you fucks.
We'll see you guys tomorrow
with my good pal Tommy Segura.
And then we will return again on
Thursday with the great Mac Danzig.
So, uh, looking forward to this
very much. And uh, we have, uh,
have yourself a great weekend. My
new studio is done. I got the lease.
Brian and I are going to go check it
out tomorrow and we start planning the
clock. Guys going to do some stuff for us.
It's going to build some awesome. Yeah,
that guy's awesome. Alright. Alright.
We love you guys. Thank you. Bye.
Okay.
Yeah.